la technique marque ce qui est
absolument merveilleux et inespéré
alors après ce grand coup de brosse à
reluire
je vais quand même
démarré par une petite incidente ce qui
est dans le journal n'engage que le
journal appelle ça donc l'ops peut dire
exactement ce qu'il veut
ça n'engage que l'obs du reste c'est
vrai pour absolument tout ce que vous
pourrez trouver dans le journal la seule
limite est là à la ja dire le seul
contre-feu qui existe à des choses
inexactes qui se trouve dans le journal
s'appelle le procès en diffamation
c'est valable quand ça concerne d'un
individu et que l'individu ait envie de
le faire personnellement je ne les ai
jamais fait je pense que je ne le ferai
jamais puisque j'ai autre chose à faire
et quand ça ne concerne pas un individu
vous n'avez aucun contre-feu possible
donc s'il opte faire un grand titre de
une en dix ans la terre est plate
aucun contre-feu possible cette personne
ne peut faire un procès en disant à
l'ops vont raconter des carabistouilles
on va vous traînez au tribunal voilà
donc je vous rappelle que le journal
n'engage que le journal quand il publie
quelque chose et que ça ne peut jamais
être une source d'informations opposable
quand vous avez une décision sérieuse à
prendre enfin en tout cas je vous le
conseille
alors ce que je vais essayer de vous
dire aujourd'hui si je ne me prends pas
trop mal je sais pas si ça va faire de
moi une star des milieux écolo mais ça
va devrait de faire de moi une anti star
d'une bonne partie de vos profs
d'économie
parce que je vais essayer de vous
expliquer que une bonne partie de ce
qu'on vous apprend une bonne partie de
l'illusion que nous avons que votre
avenir s'inscrira pas très très
différemment quand même dans le fil de
ce qu'ils ont ça va pas être très
différent de ce qui s'est passé avant
vient de la manière dont nous avons
conceptualiser l'économie il ya
maintenant quelques siècles de siècle et
que si on veut faire sérieusement les
choses il faut tout jeter tout ça à la
poubelle et repartir de zéro ce qui est
évidemment un peu ennuyeux et en général
les gens qui sont dans le secteur n'a
pas très envie qu'on fasse ça
alors pour ceux d'entre vous qui sont
mal réveillé que j'ai compris qu'il y
avait un petit sujet de conséquences à
moyen terme du week-end d'intégration
ce que je vais vous dire ce matin peut
se résumer en cette égalité
c'est à dire que notre activité
économique au premier ordre et en
tendance longue se résume à la quantité
d'énergie disponible et au premier ordre
et en tendance longue ça vous donne les
émissions de co2 qui vont dans la grande
poubelle atmosphérique donc en gros
on ne fait pas une erreur
importante en considérant que
l'économie c'est de l'énergie et à cette
énergie c'est des combustibles fossiles
alors avant de
vous montrer des tas de courbes qui
montent et qui descendent je vais
essayer de commencer par un petit dessin
animé alors c'est un petit dessin animé
à ma sauce d'ingénieurs donc c'est pas
exactement comme ce qui sort des studios
pixar mais pour essayer de vous montrer
comment est ce que quand on a une
lecture physique de l'économie parce que
l'énergie c'est de la physique
on peut voir la façon dont nos activités
productives se déroule alors ça c'est la
planète terre qui comme le disait
coluche écart avec les yeux dans les
coins
donc c'est l'ensemble enfin c'est une
planète terre treize entrepôts centres
et c'est à dire ces grands supermarchés
de ressources dans lequel on peut aller
se servir et ses ressources en bande
ingénieurs que je suis je les ai classée
dans 2 tiroirs il ya celles qui ne se
renouvelle pas à l'échelle d'une vie
humaine par exemple le minerai de cuivre
par exemple le minerai de plomb par
exemple la surface terrestre treize
mille kilomètres de diamètre la terre ça
changera pas beaucoup de votre vivant et
puis il ya celles que l'on peut
considérer comme pouvant se renouveler à
l'échelle d'une vie humaine typiquement
l'herbe ou éventuellement les poissons
et alors la première chose que je vais
vous rappeler j'insisterai beaucoup là
dessus je crois que ça vous a déjà été
dit mais comme disait mon père qui s'y
connaissaient puisqu'ils étaient
enseignants en enseignements et allons à
bascharage
ces ressources sont gratuites
ces ressources sont apparus autour de
nous avec le résultat de 14 milliards
d'années d'évolution depuis le big bang
c'est à dire depuis la grande soupe de
protons qu'il y avait dans l'univers
la première génération des toiles a fait
tous les éléments du tableau de
mendeleïev donc lors de vos bijoux de
même que le carbone de vos corps de même
que l'oxygène que vous respirez de même
que le plomb qui ne se change pas en or
enfin pas facilement tout ça est apparu
dans la première génération des toiles
avec la nature qui a jouer au mécano en
faisant à partir de protons tous les
éléments du tableau de mendeleïev donc
de 1 à 92 proto en passant par le
lithium qui en ce moment nous intéresse
beaucoup
et puis la matière de ses premières
générations des toiles s'est dispersée
dans l'univers à la suite de la mort de
cette première génération des toiles ça
a fait des grands nuages de poussière
fois des nuages pointent des grands
enfin ça fait des poussières qu'ils sont
baladés à droite et à gauche et de temps
en temps cette poussière a fait l'objet
d'un phénomène d'accrétion autour d'une
nouvelle génération d'étoilés en
formation et c'est comme ça qu'ils aider
la planète terre planète tellurique qui
a donc rassemblé les 92 éléments du
tableau de mendeleïev de l'hydrogène à
l'uranium
gratos d'accord il n'y a pas eu de
business plan c'est par un élève de le
scp pour savoir comment est ce qu'on
allait faire la planète terre tout ça
s'est fait tranquillement pendant que
nous n'existions même pas et puis cette
planète apparaît a le bon goût de
développer la vie aujourd'hui des
dizaines de millions des centaines de
millions d'espèces vivantes a le bon
goût de nous donner des continents des
océans un système climatique des
pingouins sur l'épaule très bien pour
faire la marche de l'empereur et c'est
donc tout ça gratos pas payer un radis
pour ça pas payer un centime pas un
rouble pas un kopeck d'accord
et puis nous apparaissons alors nous
nous sommes très intelligent parce que
nous allons à l'école et donc on
comprend un truc quand nous apparaissons
sais que de temps en temps c'est ça qui
a fait le succès de l'espèce humaine
nous pouvons extraire des ressources de
l'environnement et en faire autre chose
donc on considère comme étant plus
sympathique plus utile pour nous alors
au début c'est tailler des pierres ça va
pas chercher très loin maintenant nous
faisons des machines nespresso c'est
quand même vachement mieux mais le
principe est toujours le même on extrait
des ressources de l'environnement on les
transforme par notre activité ce qu'on
appelle le travail et on en fait
autorise alors au début on n'est
vraiment pas nombreux on n'est vraiment
pas productif donc ce qu'on extrait de
l'environnement imperceptible sur les
stocks de ressources renouvelables et
s'est déjà perceptible sur les stocks de
ressources non renouvelables par exemple
paléolithique qui a eu des pénuries
locales de silex taillables mais déjà
mais ils n'étaient pas cotées à la
bourse de chicago donc on sait pas quel
était le prix à ce moment-là eux mais
par contre tout ça reste reste reste
faible et puis un jour et j'y reviendrai
longuement dans cet exposé nous
découvrons que nous pouvons maîtriser
des esclaves énergétiques alors j'y
reviendrai sur ces esclaves énergétique
que nous pouvons maîtriser parce que
c'est allé de nos semblables jusqu au
laminoir c est le principe de l'esclave
énergétique c'est qu'il démultiplient
nos propres forces c'est ça qui sert
donc nous devenons capable d'extraire
plus vite et de manière plus j'ai envie
de dire efficace des ressources de
l'environnement et de les transformer et
puis on écoute les cours d'épreuve de le
scp et on découvre le capital on y
remarque j'en sais rien alors on fait le
capital on ne découvre pas qu'est ce que
c'est que le capital c'est tout
simplement une partie de la production
passée qu'on peut conserver pour la
mettre au profit d'une augmentation de
la production future qu'il s'agisse d'un
stock de brevets ou d'un immeuble le
capital c'est ça c'est un truc qu'on
peut mettre au profit de la production
future et qui ne se détruit pas quand on
s'en sert par exemple cet immeuble qui
était un élément de capital normalement
ne s'effondre pas qu'on fait des
conférences pas prévu pour sinon ça fait
les gros titres des journaux donc le
capital c'est exactement ça alors on
trouve que tout ça est vachement bien et
puis ça nous profite donc nous croissons
et multiplions et donc nous augmentons à
chaque fois la production et plus on
augmente la production plus on tape dans
le stock de ressources non renouvelables
qui diminue c'est fatal d'accord c'est
vrai qu'elles que soient les ressources
et puis à un moment nous devenons
tellement nombreux et tellement
productif que même les ressources
renouvelables se mettent à diminuer le
stock de poissons est aujourd'hui
beaucoup plus petit que ce qu'il était
il ya un siècle le stock de fort est
aujourd'hui plus petit que ce qu'il
était il ya un siècle et c'est en tout
ni stock de ressources renouvelables 10
minutes et puis dans cette activité de
transformation débridée nous créons des
sous produits indésirables d'accord on
ne peut pas faire le merveilleux
shampoing de chez l'oréal s'en extraire
du pétrole et donc 200 longtemps sans
avoir quelques résidus liés à
l'extraction du pétrole on ne peut pas
faire ça s'en extraire quelques minéraux
qui vont servir de pigments et donc on a
des terrils dominé les trous dans la
terre voilà donc on fait des sous
produits indésirables qui s'appelle la
pollution est alors en termes techniques
la pollution c'est des substances qu'on
met dans l'environnement et qui vont
dégrader la qualité des actifs restants
c'est ça en termes scientifiques ou
techniques la pollution c'est une
dégradation des actifs naturels restants
via des substances indésirables qu'on
met dans l'environnement donc voilà
physiquement comment se décrit
l'activité de production qui fait
aujourd'hui l'objet de très belles
théories dans lesquelles il ya de
l'utilité marginale et tout un tas
d'autres trucs auxquels j'ai jamais rien
compris donc vous avez jamais rien
compris parce que je pense que ça sert à
quelque chose donc le voilà voilà la
description de l'activité physique et
nous dans cette affaire objectivement
vous dans cette affaire vous allez
apprendre que ça
vous allez apprendre de l'économie c'est
à dire quelque chose qui est basé sur un
système de prix il est pris c'est quoi
c'est la contribution humaine en
salaires et en rente à cette activité de
transformation c'est juste ça un prix
tout ce que vous avez payé pour acquérir
un objet ça n'est qu'un empilement de
salir et de rentes dans le processus de
transformations successives qui est
partie des ressources naturelles pour
aller jusqu'à l'objet que vous achetez
donc le grand paradoxe quand vous
achetez inverse que vous n'achetez pas
le maire vous n'achetez que les salaires
et les rentes des gens qui ont été
chercher le sable le carbonate de
calcium qui ont été chercher le minerai
de fer tout ça est gratuit pour
construire le four à verre qui ont été
chercher le gaz former gratuitement pour
alimenter le four à verre etc vous ne
payez que ça
que ça d'accord vous ne payez pas le
vert les atomes du verre vous ont été
donnés gratuitement par la nature
évidemment dans un alors dans ce système
là on peut croire et du reste si un
certain nombre d'économistes qui le
croient malgré la blague de boulding que
vous connaissez probablement un
quelqu'un qui croit que la croissance
infinie est possible et son influx soit
un économiste et il n'ya beaucoup
d'économistes
donc quand vous regardez ce système là
vous pouvez penser effectivement que la
croissance perpétuelle est possible
puisqu'il suffit en théorie d'augmenter
le nombre de bonnes âmes et comme vous
voyez pas de facteurs limitants
physiquement vous dites bon milliards 10
milliards 12 14 why not
et il suffit de les payer de plus en
plus cher et puis voilà et puis et puis
le pib augmente où est le problème 1
pour employer une taille n'est qu'une
expression qui appartient à la
génération wtf alors en fait si on avait
décidé d'avoir une comptabilité
actif-passif un peu sérieuse dans cette
affaire c'est pas ça qu'on aurait fait
on aurait dit à chaque fois que je crée
quelque chose je compte en plus à chaque
fois que je décris que je détruis part
dans quelque chose je compte en moins et
le jour où la valeur marginale de la
dernière voiture que j'ai construite est
inférieure à la destruction marginale du
dernier minerai de fer et du dernier
pétrole que j'ai extrait pour faire le
plastique pour construire cette voiture
je m'arrête de faire des voitures et
comme dit la fin de tout conte de fées
je vis happily ever after avec les
voitures existantes
à l'évidence c'est pas ça qu'on fait
alors on pourra au moment du débat se
poser la question de savoir pourquoi
c'est pas ça qu'on fait il ya des gens
qui pensent que on est câblé
biologiquement pour ne pas être capable
de faire autre chose que ça mais c'est
bien ça le c'est bien ça le sujet alors
dans cette affaire je le redis il ya
l'énergie qui joue un rôle absolument
centrale est donc maintenant on va se
mettre à parler d'énergie alors des fois
je fais des grands entre ceux qui ont
déjà vu des grands passages en
expliquant à l'énergie on croit que
c'est ceci alors là je vais aller
directement à la réponse voilà l'énergie
c'est ça
ça c'est iron man vous reconnaissez
probablement qui pourrait être iron man
ou iron personnes dur et je me demande
pourquoi est ce que les gens n'ont pas
demandé à ce qui s'appelle iron personne
peu importe donc il a une belle armure
la lumière blanche là qui clignotent au
milieu et dès qu'il a enfilé son armure
il est capable de faire n'importe quoi
alors en fait il se trouve que l'armure
d'iron man on en dispose aussi elle a
juste pas la forme d'une armure et à
cette formule 1 voilà mais ça c'est iron
man c'est iron man à nous c'est le parc
mondial de laminoir de raffineries
d'aspirateurs de tourniquets tafer la
vinaigrette comme disait vian
deux tractopelles de four à verre de
machine à laver c'est ça iron man pour
nous c'est ce parc mondial donc mon pied
gauche il court à 2000 km heure c'est un
avion de chasse mon pied droit il est
capable de taper dans une masse de
centaines de millions de tonnes c'est
par exemple tout le commerce mondial mon
petit doigt droit il est capable de
soulever les plus lourdes charges ça
s'appelle une grue et c'est donc ironman
ils existent pour de vrai nous sommes
tous devenus des ironman et d iron man
et on le doit au parc mondial de
machines et que consomme le parc mondial
de machines de l'énergie donc en fait
l'énergie c'est la bibine d'iron man
tessa l'énergie c'est pas autre chose
c'est la bil in d'iron man alors voilà
quelques sous-ensembles d'iron man que
je vais vous donner alors je vous fais
pas le calcul mais enfin il est
disponible sur plein de conférences en
ligne vous dirait de voir si vous voulez
pour ceux d'entre vous qui cet été par
exemple sont amusés à faire de la
montagne sachez que si vous montez sur
le mont blanc au sommet du mont blanc en
partant de chamonix dans la journée mais
fort sympathique et bien vous aurait
fourni à kilowattheures d'énergie
mécanique avec vos jambes je précise
avec vos jambes parce que ceux qui font
ça sur les bras sont quand même assez
rare
si vous faites un petit calcul au
premier ordre c'est à dire que la
puissance c'est les nerfs c'est
l'énergie / le temps et bien vous vous
rendez compte que vos jambes sont
capables de fournir une puissance
moyenne de 100 watts dans la journée
alors ça serait exactement pareil ici le
bizutage ici consistait à monter à peu
près cette fois au pardon 14 fois sur la
tour eiffel dans la journée à pied en
jeu précise pas dans l'ascenseur et que
les touristes
voilà c'est pareil vous fournir y ait
une énergie mécanique de l'ordre d'un
kilowatt heure donc une puissance
moyenne de 100 watts dans la journée
alors maintenant on va prendre un
premier appareil qu'on trouve dans une
cuisine imaginons un mixeur à soupe
déjà utilisé un mixeur à soupe
oui qui a jamais utiliser de mixeur à
soupe dans cette pièce
il ya quelques courageux qui se dénonce
quand même
donc ça veut dire qu'il ya encore des
gens qui ont des domestiques
donc quand vous utilisez un mixeur à
soupe vous savez c'est un truc que vous
plongez dans les légumes like effet dit
bon et bien au moment vous appuyez sur
le bouton et que ça fait dit vous avez
quatre paires de jambes qui se mettent à
pédaler pour vous donc au moment où vous
appuyez sur le bouton de ce truc
ridicule qui coûte 50 balles dans chez
un distributeur sûrement géré par un
aspect que je ne nommerai pas et bien
vous avez quatre personnes qui se
mettent à travailler pour vous c'est
juste pas le même prix est d'accord si
vous deviez avoir quatre domestique chez
vous pour le coup qui mixe la soupe avec
leurs rites leurs jambes ça vous
coûterait pas le même prix que d'acheter
un mixeur à soupe
même ceux que j'avais mixer dessous vous
avez quand même passé un aspirateur
oui ça me tenait bon c'est ce que c'est
qu'un aspirateur moment où vous appuyez
sur le bouton de l'aspirateur l'acédie
cycliste qui se mettent à pédales y
prend goût c'est à dire que la puissance
du moteur de l'aspirateur
c'est une dizaine de paires de jambes en
moyenne alors là encore on parle de
trucs bon pas terrible maintenant
certains d'entre vous ont peut-être des
gens qui travaillent dans l'agriculture
dans leur famille or là on va parler de
trucs un peu plus sérieux vous montez
dans tracteur au moment où l'agriculteur
monde dans son tracteur et là je prends
un petit tracteur et bien il devient
effectivement iron agriculteurs pour de
vrai puisqu'il démultiplie la puissance
de ses jambes par six ans
commence à devenir un peu plus sérieux
au moment où l'ouvrier des travaux
publics monde dans son tractopelle là il
démultiplie la puissance de ses bras par
10000 à commence vraiment à devenir un
peu plus sérieux au moment où roberge
pas pourquoi les conducteurs de camions
ça fait toujours robert monde dans son
camion
lui il démultiplie la puissance de ses
jambes par 4000 donc c'est pas les gens
qui transportent les marchandises c'est
les camions qui transportent les
marchandises si vous avez toujours des
conducteurs de camions et pas de camion
paris meurent de faim
sans camion paris nord 2 1 et au moment
où l'ouvrier qui pilote le laminoir de
dunkerque ou de fos-sur-mer rentrer dans
la cabine de pilotage du laminoir l'aï
multiplient la puissance de ses bras par
10 millions alors je vais vous le dire
autrement si en france nous n'avions pas
les laminoirs de dunkerque et de
fos-sur-mer pour avoir la même quantité
de thau laminé avec des gens qui tapent
la tôle avec des marteaux je devrai
mettre dans le laminage des tôles la
totalité de la population active
française
donc vous feriez pas d'études à l'ehess
cp je peux vous dire vous apprendriez à
taper sur une tôle et qu'un marteau qui
du reste on pourra rien d'en faire
derrière de la tôle laminé puisque toute
la population active serait dans le
laminage des tôles dont qui aurait
absolument personne derrière pour faire
des voitures et des boutons pression
personnes d'accord toute la population
donc les machines que nous utilisons
aujourd'hui sont totalement surpuissante
et en fait ce sont elles qui produisent
c'est pas les gens qui produisent c'est
elle qui produisent pour vos anciens qui
sont dans la distribution il ne serait
rien s'il n'y avait pas les camions les
voitures des clients les industries qui
ont fabriqué les produits les machines
qui servent à chauffer ou refroidir les
magasins mettez les géants de la
distribution au milieu du vide
intersidéral sans énergie et sans
machine ils sont un poil
au sens propre du terme d'appui non plus
de vêtements à vendre donc le
et alors comme dans ce film dont je me
rappelle plus le nom là s'ils n'y vont
pas durer très longtemps donc le la
production aujourd'hui l'économie
mondiale aujourd'hui c'est un système de
machine nous on est juste là pour leur
donner des ordres pour l'essentiel
d'entre vous on vous couperait vos deux
bras vos deux jambes je ne vous souhaite
pas mais enfin et on vous donnerait la
possibilité de piloter un ordinateur
avec votre cervelle vous feriez le votre
métier de la même manière
pour faire du powerpoint et du tableur
excel
à quoi ça vous sert vos bras et vos
jambes si vous êtes capable de piloter
votre ordinateur à la voix rien tu es
d'accord à rien donc tout ce qu'on va
utiliser chez vous c'est pas votre corps
c'est pas votre puissance productive
musculaire mécanique c'est juste votre
capacité à piloter un système de machine
c'est juste moi c'est pareil j'avoue moi
c'est exactement pareil
et alors ce système de machine quand
vous regardez quelle est la puissance
qu'il est capable de développer alimenté
avec sabine particulière qui s'appelle
l'énergie eh bien vous vous rendez
compte qu'il est capable de multiplier
la puissance musculaire de l'humanité
par 200 envoyé 2 mondial est en france
c'est plutôt par six ans
donc je vais vous le dire autrement
grâce aux machines et à l'énergie le
smicard français vit comme un nabab il
s'en rend pas compte vous vider comme
des super nabab il s'en rend pas compte
il est pas content parce que vous vivez
mieux que lui mais en attendant même lui
au regard de ce qui était la condition
d'un paysan il ya deux siècles il vit
comme un nabab
il vit comme un nabab il a un carrosse
qui l'emmène à 100 km/heure d'une
pression du pied le roi de france
n'avaient pas accès à ça il ya quelques
siècles
et alors la traduction de ce que je
viens de vous dire et c'est une
conséquence ce n'est pas une
démonstration c'est une conséquence
attendue à partir du moment où vous avez
un parc de machines qui représente une
capacité de transformation de tout ce
qui nous entoure qui est 200 fois
supérieur à la capacité de
transformation des individus vous devez
logiquement vous attendre à ce que la
taille de l'économie au sens de la
taille du pib soit avant tout une
conséquence de la taille du parc de
machines en service
d'accord avec moi mes hommes sont
négligeables et les femmes aussi je suis
désolé de le dire dans cette histoire ce
qui compte encore une fois c'est la
taille du parc de machines en service
pour si on n'avait pas les machines
alors je vais avant de passer à la
suivante un petit truc qu'il faut se
dire c'est que pour avoir le même pib
mondial il faudrait multiplier la
population humaine par 200 alors déjà
qui a 8 milliards on a quelques
problèmes de place
je gens d'y jouer à huit milliards tout
va bien alors et l'expérience n'est pas
terminée et bien à 8 soit 200
c'est-à-dire 1600 milliards si je ne me
trompe pas on aurai je crois quelques
petits problèmes de places
supplémentaires et malgré le génie de
messieurs bizos et musk je ne suis pas
complètement sûr qu'on irait en met
1599 des milliards sur mars
donc
évidemment qu'on pourrait pas sans
machine avoir la même taille de
l'économie est en fait voilà la
traduction voilà commencé à rentrer dans
les courbes de ce que je viens de vous
dire vous avez ici un graphique sur
lequel j'ai commencé à faire ça peu par
curiosité pour voir la tête que ça avait
il ya dix ans alors intellectuellement
j'ai fait le chemin inverse d'abord j'ai
vu cette courbe ensuite je me suis dit
mais comment ça se fait que cette courbe
cette tête est en fait je suis à ce
moment j'ai fini j'ai mis du temps parce
que je suis vieux élan par comprendre
que la raison elle était là c'est à dire
qu'en fait la courbe à sept têtes c'est
normal puisque l'économie dépend de la
taille du parc de machines or la
quantité d'énergie qu'on utilise c'est
la taille du parc de machines en service
j'insiste en service si les machines
n'ont pas d'énergie pour fonctionner
elles sont pas en service elles servent
à rien taille du parc de machines en
service alors on peut regarder non
seulement ce genre d'évolution pour
regarder les dérivés alors je vous en
proposer une
voilà ici de dérivés en l'occurrence de
variation en rouge vous avez la
variation de la production mondiale de
pétrole donc il s'agit pas d'un prix il
s'agit de la quantité de barils qui
sortent de terre et en bleu vous avez la
variation du pib par personne dans le
monde et vous voyez que quand vous avez
un décalage temporel orco vide où ça
s'est passé dans l'autre sens eh bien
vous avez d'abord la production qui
descend et ensuite le pib qui suit ça
veut donc dire que le pétrole est un
facteur limitant de l'économie mondiale
si j'en ai plus l'économie est plus
importante si j'en ai moins l'économie
est moins importante évidemment il ya
d'autres facteurs limitants de
l'économie mondiale si tout le monde
meurt d'une épidémie ça sera un facteur
limitant du reste avec le candidat sap a
été le pétrole le facteur limitant mais
hors accidents sanitaires et on va dire
hors accident tout court c'est à dire
hors phénomène transitoire
depuis plusieurs dizaines d'années le
premier facteur limitant de l'économie
mondiale ça a été le volume et j'incite
le volume pas le prix de pétrole dont
nous disposons voilà c'est ça donc si
vous voulez faire un pari sur ce qu'est
le pib l'année d'après ou deux ans après
vous regardez la quantité de pétrole qui
sort des puits à mon avis vous pouvez
risquer une bière
voire même une bouffe au restaurant
alors cette énergie que nous avons
mises dans les machines elle n'a pas
cessé de croître depuis la révolution
industrielle et vous voyez sur ce
graphique qui vous donne les quantités
d'énergie utilisée dans le monde que
chaque énergie est venu s'empiler sur
les précédentes donc pour le moment il
n'y a jamais eu de phénomène de
substitution à large échelle
vous avez le charbon qui est venue se
rajouter aux bois qui est là et jamais
on a utilisé autant de charbon dans le
monde qu'aujourd'hui en première
approximation puits de pétrole est venue
se rajouter par dessus le gaz et
d'électricité nucléaire et alors là tout
en haut là vous avez ce qui excite les
journalistes là les nouvelles énergies
renouvelables et dont un certain nombre
de politiques disent que nous allons
remplacer tout ce qui est en dessous
tout ça grâce à ça en 30 ans et à
quantité d'énergie croissante puisque
nous allons continuer à faire croître le
pib bon là aussi je pense que vous
prenez pas un grand risque en pariant
une bouffée même beaucoup plus sur le
fait que ça n'arrivera pas et je vais
essayer de vous montrer pourquoi
ce que vous voyez également c'est qu'il
ya plein d'éléments qui sont parfois
avancé dans le débat public comme étant
des choses qui permettent d'être plus
efficace alors par exemple quand on met
les gens dans les villes ils se
déplacent sur des distances plus courtes
et du coup c'est plus efficacement vous
voyez les villes elles ont commencé à se
développer à ce moment là
l'effet sur la consommation mondiale
d'énergie n'a pas l'air manifeste
on dit l'économie c'est tertiarisée donc
ça permet de baisser la quantité
d'énergie qu'on utilise bas quand vous
regardez cette courbe s'est pas
complètement sûrs alors j'ai pas le
temps aujourd'hui mais il ya une qu'on a
enregistré en deux conférences que j'ai
donné à centrale nantes il est loin
trois heures enfin la vérité tu as pris
je suis rentré dans les détails je
montre des tas de courbes dans lesquels
je regarde la corrélation qui existe
entre les émissions de co2 par personne
et la fraction des gens qui habitent en
ville
est alors en fait ce que j'obtiens comme
résultat c'est que à peu près partout la
fraction des gens qui habitent en ville
va avec une augmentation de la quantité
de co2 par personne et tu fais pas du
tout l'inversé et en fait quand on
réfléchit à ce que ça veut dire
physiquement ça s'explique mais j'ai pas
le temps d'aujourd'hui
la digitalisation est censé nous faire
économiser de l'énergie bas à nouveau
regarder la digitalisation ainsi apparu
alors vous étiez panne et
les faits là dessus
pas non plus totalement manifeste donc
locaux vides ça a l'air de marcher
beaucoup mieux
donc effectivement quelques bonnes
pandémie
ont probablement un effet plus
discriminant sur l'évolution de la
consommation d'énergie que tout ce qu'on
peut raconter aujourd'hui comme étant
des trouvailles de ceci de cela donc il
ya un premier enseignement que je vous
conseille d'avoir c'est quand vous
entendez une théorie en disant tel ou
tel truc permet d'être plus efficace
méfiez-vous de deux choses c'est que
tout le monde confond dans cette affaire
l'énergie par cafetière et l'énergie
totale des cafetières or ce qui compte
c'est l'énergie totale des cafetières
l'énergie par cafetière ça ne vous dit
rien sur la façon dont évolue votre
problème parce qu'il suffit que le
nombre de cafetière augmente plus vite
ce que l'énergie par cafetière de baisse
est votre problème augmente
donc méfiez vous de la confusion entre
les ratios et les valeurs absolues et
une large partie du greenwashing des
entreprises qui greenwash à tout va en
ce moment vient de là
ça vient d'eux je m'améliore sur les
ratios mais en fait s'améliorer sur les
ratios c'est souvent des coudes des
coûts de production en moins tout le
monde est d'accord mais absolument pas
sur les valeurs absolues parce que les
valeurs absolues en général pour limiter
la production pour être capable de
s'améliorer dessus alors ça c'est pas
exactement ce qu'on vous apprend en
général pendant vos études de limiter la
production
l'essentiel de cette énergie qu'on
utilise aujourd'hui c'est des
combustibles fossiles alors à la au
moment des chocs pétroliers on est passé
on était à 80 % de combustibles fossiles
dans la consommation mondiale d'énergie
donc le parc mondial de machines
utilisées à 80% des combustibles
fossiles et aujourd'hui nous sommes à
80 %
donc le la quantité d'énergie fossiles
qu'on utilise en proportion dans ce qui
alimente le parc de machines dans le
monde est resté à peu près le même sur
les 50 dernières années c'est
essentiellement les combustibles
fossiles on verra un tout petit peu
pourquoi est ce que c'est normal que ce
soit comme ça c'est également vrai dans
l'électricité ici vous avez la
génération électrique par sources
primaires utilisé alors l'essentiel de
la génération électrique c'est vrai pour
le charbon c'est vrai pour le gaz c'est
vrai pour le pétrole c'est vrai pour le
nucléaire
consiste à faire beaucoup de chaleur
avec ça vous fait beaucoup de vapeur et
vous fait tourner une turbine
bête comme chou c'est une grosse machine
à vapeur ça c'est bête comme chou donc
c'est très compliqué mais le principe
est bête comme chou c'est des grosses
machines à vapeur
là vous fait encore tourner un truc
c'est une turbine est donc là vous avez
les nouvelles énergies renouvelables le
vent le solaire et le biogaz l'allemagne
par exemple un million d'hectares c'est
beaucoup pour un pays qui doit en faire
40 ou 45 de maïs fourrage qui ne sert
qu'à faire du méthane pour alimenter des
méthaniseurs
donc c'est aussi un mode de production
n'en parle pas beaucoup
en allemagne ça veut dire que c'est
time's up
le ça veut dire que le
patron n'en parle pas beaucoup mais
c'est à peu près aussi important que le
solaire en allemagne en termes de
production électrique un le biogaz et ça
occupe énormément de surface
plus de 60% aujourd'hui de la production
électrique mondiale est fait avec des
fossiles on continue à construire à tire
larigot des centrales à charbon des
centrales à gaz partout en europe parce
qu'on n'aime pas le nucléaire etc et
quand on regarde comment ces décarbonés
les pas l'électricité pardon de
l'énergie mondiale depuis 1965 ben voilà
une courbe qui est que ça se déclare
boîte pas c'est à dire que si je vous
mets l'énergie consommée d'un côté les
émissions de co2 venant de l'énergie de
l'autre si l'énergie ce des carbonnais
ça devrait baisser enfin la courbe
devrait être complexe au con carne en
conquête en
peau de vache infléchir
et comme la quantité d'énergie fossile
en gros suit la quantité d'énergie tout
court qui suit le l'évolution économique
ou qui la précède plus exactement eh
bien vous avez ici le drame des
négociations climat qui est
qu'aujourd'hui faire baisser les
émissions de co2 sans faire baisser le
pib on sait pas faire
et mon pari c'est qu'à l'avenir dans les
bon ordre de grandeur on ne saura pas
faire non plus
j'ai essayé d'y venir derrière on ne
sera pas faire non plus donc si le scp
doit être sérieuse ou sur you
tube sérieuse vous avez un genre ici le
féminin bon alors très bien sérieuse
sur la question du changement climatique
elle doit vous apprendre roulement de
tambour à travailler dans une économie
en contraction perpétuelle
ah
adieu les business plans dans un monde
en croissance
à vous apprend ça aujourd'hui non donc
on vous apprend pas ce qui est vraiment
utile
enfin en tout cas si on veut régler ce
problème alors ce problème finira par se
régler toute façon j'y viendrai à la fin
de voix là et le monde sans croissance
finira par arriver de toute façon et
donc comme ça finira par arriver de
toute façon vaut mieux de près comme dit
le mouvement étudiant 1
voilà donc je résume à ces une autre une
autre lecture de ce que je viens de vous
raconter
la terre nous a donnés gratuitement
comme tout le reste des gisements
d'hydrocarbures puisque personne n'a
rien payé pour la formation du pétrole
qui est aussi gratuite le vent
les hydrocarbures brûlent alimentant des
machines ça permet de transformer tout
le reste de ce qui nous tombe sous la
main et tout le reste de ce qui nous
tombe sous la main a tellement modifié
la façon dont nous vivons que ça a
modifié les métiers donc là c'est pareil
j'ai pas le temps de vous le dire mais
pour ceux d'entre vous que ça intéresse
vous pourrez regarder le premier module
de mon cours aux mines qui est
disponible en ligne a et qui détaille
tout ça de façon un peu plus approfondie
et notamment comment est-ce que
l'abondance énergétique en augmentant la
taille du parc de machines là totalement
déformé la structure des métiers il ya
deux siècles les deux tiers des français
étaient agriculteurs dont il ya deux
siècles vous n'auriez pas été à l'ocp où
seriez en train de ramasser les patates
le monde avant l'énergie abondante
c'était ça ont ramassé des patates
l'agriculture était peu productive il
n'y avait pas de ville là aussi
j'explique pourquoi dans la foi secours
et puis dans le la conférence centrale
nantes dont je vous ai parlé
la plus grande ville du monde c'était
enfin une des plus grandes villes du
monde s'était rome parce qu'on pouvait
drainés par voie maritime le blé
égyptien mais toutes les villes qui
étaient dans les terres étaient
incapables de dépasser il ya l'époque de
l'antiquité quelques dizaines de
milliers d'habitants très très dur de
dépasser quelques dizaines de milliers
d'habitants il n'y avait pas d' emplois
de service à part les domestiques y
avait enfin voilà tout ça est apparue
par le biais de l'énergie abondante la
quasi totalité des métiers qu'on apprend
aujourd'hui doivent quelque chose à
l'énergie accord sans énergie on peut
pas les exercer
c'est également grâce à l'énergie qu'on
travaille moins longtemps donc on a
développé les vacances les études
longues la retraite les week-ends et les
35 heures par semaine voilà tout ça
c'est des effets de l'énergie abondante
et ça ne doit que très marginalement
revendications conjugués de la cgt et du
medef
donc le la mondialisation c'est pareil
sans porte conteneurs et 100 avions fait
pas de mondialisation donc le la
l'énergie en fait à totalement
totalement structure et le monde qui
nous entoure j'ai bien totalement
structure et le monde qui nous entoure
et dans cette affaire on a choisi de
conter le pib est un des gros défauts
qu'on a aujourd'hui c'est de considérer
que toute la vérité est dans les prix
une fois qu'on a les prix on a toute
l'information disponible pour spéculer
sur l'avenir alors je vais vous donner
un exemple tout con issus du monde
physique pour vous montrer que c'est
faux la production électrique la moins
chère que nous ayons en france en ce
moment qui par ailleurs est renouvelable
c'est l'hydroélectricité
hydroélectricité c'est la production
électrique la moins chère donc si un
prix bas est représentatif de la
facilité à faire plus tard on se dit pas
très bien puisque le prix est bas yakhi
en faire partout parce que si c'est pas
cher c'est que c'est ça qu'il faut faire
sauf que manque de pot rajouter des
barrages un peu plus en france on a
équipé tout ce qu'on pouvait et pourquoi
on ne peut plus parce que le prix bas ne
vous dit rien sur la condition physique
nécessaire pour que vous ayez de prix
bas ça ne vous dit rien dessus le prix
ne vous dit rien là dessus donc un prix
bas aujourd'hui ne vous dit rien sur la
capacité à déployer demain c'est
désagréable
mais c'est comme ça
donc il faut sortir des prix si on veut
comprendre le monde qui nous entoure et
on doit revenir pour tous phénomènes
économiques assez sous jacent physique
dans lesquels il y à un confort
intellectuel même si c'est très
désagréable parieurs qui est que dans la
physique ya des lois qui dépendent pas
de nous alors c'est à la fois très
désagréable parce que si ça dépend pas
de nous c'est qu'on n'a pas de prise
dessus on peut pas changer la loi de
conservation de l'énergie par un vote à
l'assemblée nationale même si beaucoup
de ministres de l'ecologie aimerait bien
et beaucoup de présidents aimerait bien
aussi mais par contre ça a un énorme
avantage les lois qui dépendent pas de
nous c'est que ça permet de faire de
vrais prévisions parce que s'il ya une
personne dans cette salle qui me sort un
modèle macroéconomique qui est capable
de me faire une vraie prévisions à 20
ans là je peux vous assurer que je
l'offre le restaurant pour un certain
nombre d'années ça n'existe pas ça
n'existe pas aucun modèle
macroéconomique n'avait vu venir la
crise du coc vide aucun modèle
macroéconomique n'a vu venir la crise de
2008 ça n'existe pas un modèle
macroéconomique prédictif ça n'existe
pas alors que les modèles physiques
prédictif s'il y en avait pas je peux
vous assurer que vous crachent leur y
est à chaque fois vous prendrez l'avion
ce qui est très mal du reste même si
vous allez beaucoup le prendre quand
votre scolarité à ce qui est une très
mauvaise chose
et bah oui on vous donne pas le bon
exemple et par ailleurs
c'est vraiment faites ce que je dis pas
ce que je fais quoi et par ailleurs le
qu'est ce que je veux dire le capacité
des modèles physiques à être prédictif
et évidemment considérablement plus
élevée que celle des modèles économiques
alors notre affaire à deux facteurs
limitants et je vais rapidement
maintenant les décrire mais elle en a
beaucoup plus en fait que ça et là comme
facteur limitant les limites planétaires
qui sont du ressort de la physique ou la
biologie des espèces vivantes par
exemple alors je vais vous parler de
deux limites il y en a d'autres
la première est celle liée au changement
climatique il ya une limite en tolérance
à ce que nous pouvons supporter sur les
conditions climatiques globale sur terre
et par ailleurs je vais vous parler de
la limite amont c'est-à-dire
l'approvisionnement en hydrocarbures
sachant qu'il faut quelques dizaines à
quelques centaines de millions d'années
pour faire des hydrocarbures à partir de
la vie les hydrocarbures comme le dit
très joliment yann arthus bertrand c'est
des poches de soleil anciennes enfin des
poches ancien de soleil et c'est donc ce
n'est pas renouvelable à l'échelle des
temps historiques évidemment et donc ça
s'épuise alors on va commencer par le
premier et voici l'origine de la
perturbation climatique c'est les
émissions de gaz à effet de serre alors
là aussi je vais être obligé d'être très
rapide je suis désolé un gaz à effet de
serre à une définition très précise en
physique c'est un gaz qui possèdent des
red absorption dans l'infrarouge
terrestre je suis désolé de vous dire
que c'est ça la définition d'un gaz à
effet de serre c'est un gaz qui
possèdent des raies d'absorption dans
l'infrarouge terrestre donc pour savoir
à ce que c'est qu'un gaz à effet de
serre faut avoir fait un tout petit peu
de mécanique quantique sais pas si
beaucoup d'entre vous on en fait dans
voilà y avoir vu ce que c'était que des
transitions électronique dans une
molécule sinon vous êtes obligé de faire
confiance aux gens qui ont fait ça et
par monsieur christian gérondeau
et l'effet de serre est connu depuis
deux siècles
c'est fourier cocorico qui a découvert
sa en 1824 et les gaz à effet de serre
principaux de l'atmosphère sert le co2
la vapeur d'eau sont connues depuis un
siècle et demi tout ça est de la vieille
science donc on sait depuis très
longtemps que le
l'effet de serre existe sur terre qu'ils
pilotent le clifa qu'ils contribuent au
pilotage du climat et les grands gaz qui
en sont à l'origine lorsque vous voyez
là c'est les émissions de gaz à effet de
serre dues aux activités humaines alors
voyez c'est pareil vous pouvez imaginer
tout ce tout ce que vous voulez comme
causes qui irait dans le sens d'une
inflexion de cette courbe en pratique ça
va pas marcher donc par exemple si on
électrifier les usages ça va faire moins
d'émissions pour le moment c'est pas ce
qui s'est passé en fin de toutes choses
égales par ailleurs si on met du digital
ça va faire baisser les émissions sais
pas ce qui s'est passé si on met des
trains ça va faire baisser les émissions
sais pas ce qui s'est passé si on met
internet ça à faire baisser les
émissions sais pas ce qui s'est passé
bref pour le moment rien a fait baisser
les émissions mais j'aurais pu vous
mettre là dessus les négociations climat
des fois je sors ça une courbe avec
toutes les coques les unes derrière les
autres et je montre que ça du
strictement aucun effet sur les
émissions d'accord donc le résultat
d'une coque il faut que j'étais à
copenhague c'est à copenhague que
l'objectif des 2 degrés est né sera pas
empêché la presse de dire partout que
c'était un échec donc le ce qui ce que
vous allez lire dans le journal je
reviens à mon journal
même si avec les anciens de votre école
dans l'apprécier quelques gentilles
nx100 je peux dire aussi du mal
l'opinion qu'a le journal sur le
résultat d'une coop n'engage que le
journal
ça n'engage que le journal ça ne vous
dit rien sur ce qu'il faut vraiment
penser c'est désagréable
désagréable mais vous pensez faire une
économie de temps le plus souvent vous
avez une perte de temps parce que vous
allez vous craquer dans la cervelle une
information qui n'est pas bonne
c'est comme ça
alors le co2 qui est le principal gaz à
effet de serre il a une très
sale caractéristiques dans le cas
présent c'est qu'il est inaltérable tant
qu'il est dans l'air alors pourquoi il
est inaltérable temps qu'il est dans
l'air parce que le co2 est un occident
dioxyde de carbone oxydes alors là je
vais pas faire de physique je vais faire
de la chimie il se trouve que les oxydes
sur terre sont des molécules extrêmement
stable si vous voulez pas incommoder
votre voisin ou votre voisine il ya un
oxyde que vous avez utilisé ce matin et
qui est présent sous cette forme d'oxydé
depuis des milliards d'années qui
s'appelle le lot
et bien l'eau c'est donc c'est un oxyde
c'est en oxyde d'hydrogène et ça fait
des milliards d'années que ces présents
sur terre sous forme d'eau d'accord donc
ça veut dire que ça c'est un mariage qui
dure j'ai pas quels sont les noces de 4
milliards d'années on est au delà de
l'or et du platine
mais donc ça c'est quelque chose qui est
très solide en oxyde ça se casse pas
facilement le co2 méthane oxyde donc ça
se casse pas facilement et non seulement
ça se casse pas facilement mais tant
qu'il est dans l'air je le redis il est
inaltérable ça veut dire que pour que le
co2 sorte de l'atmosphère il faut qu'ils
reviennent au contact du sol où là il
peut être épurée par deux processus qui
sont des processus longs est limité le
premier c'est la dissolution dans l'eau
océanique en fait c'est un équilibrage
de pression partielle c'est à dire que
quand il ya une concentration en co2
plus élevées dans l'air que dans l'eau
ça passe la barrière entre l'air et
l'eau mais c'est réversible ça peut se
passer dans l'autre sens si on retire du
co2 de l'atmosphère par des moyens
quelconque bien à ce moment une partie
du co2 qui était dans l'eau on repasse
dans l'air un peu mauvaise nouvelle est
le deuxième processus c'est la
photosynthèse qui est un processus qui a
besoin d'énergie si vous avez une plante
sans lumière elle pousse pas bien et
cette photo synthèse soustrait du co2 à
l'atmosphère en utilisant l'énergie du
soleil pour casser la molécule de co2 en
deux les plantes savent faire ça pas
nous donc c'est propriété assez
remarquable alors à cause de ce que je
viens de vous dire au moment où on
arrête les émissions pour les émissions
s'arrêteront fatalement au moment où on
arrête les émissions c'est pas à ce
moment là que la concentration en co2 va
tout d'un coup revenir là où elle était
avant qu'on ait commencé à émettre est
du reste un certain nombre de gens là
n'est due qu'au guidon dit ah les
émissions baisse de 5% et la
concentration en co2 ne baissent pas les
scores assez normal parce que les
émissions baisser de 5% ça fait encore
beaucoup d'émissions et c'est encore
très au delà du seuil auquel la
concentration s'arrête d'augmenter
donc après arrêt des émissions vous
attendez un siècle et au bout d'un
siècle la moitié du surplus de co2 que
nous avons créée est encore dans l'air
vous attendez un millier d'années et
entre 20 et 30% du surplus de co2 que
nous avons créée est toujours dans l'air
vous attendez dix mille ans et entre 10
et 20% du surplus de co2 que nous avons
créée est toujours dans l'air ce que je
suis en train de vous dire c'est que le
climat que nous avons entre guillemets
de trouver en entrant là comme la
propreté des toilettes quand nous avons
démarré notre activité industrielle
il est perdu à jamais
il ne reviendra jamais il ne reviendra
jamais on peut faire ce qu'on veut la
danse de la pluie c'est le cas de le
dire priez invoqué avoir tout jamais
c'est fini c'est terminé d'accord at
vitam aeternam ce qu'il reste à vivre du
temps de l'humanité pas sûr que ce soit
encore dix mille en train où vont les
choses et bien se fera dans un climat
qui aura définitivement changé par
rapport à ce qu'il était avant la
période industrielle et à cause de cette
caractéristique de l'inertie du co2 dans
l'air la dérive climatiques que nous
avons mise en route va de toute façon
continuer pour des siècles ou des
millénaires en fonction de la
conséquence que vous regardez à partir
de maintenant
et on ne peut que lutter pour limiter
l'amplitude de cette dérive on ne peut
plus l'arrêter
on ne peut plus l'arrêter alors
évidemment ça pose des petits problèmes
parce que ça ce que je viens de vous
dire s'échelonne sur des pattes temps
qui n'ont rien à voir avec un mandat
électif en démocratie ou une stratégie
de long terme dans n'importe quelle
entreprise dans laquelle vous allez
rentrer qui se baladent surtout si elle
est cotée quelque part entre 6 mois et 3
ans les bonnes années
c'est ça le drame de cette affaire c'est
que nous avons nous vivons aujourd'hui
dans une société du court terme surtout
sur absolument tous où la technologie en
fait pas la technologie l'énergie parce
que la technologie sans énergie ça sert
à rien si vous mettez un ingénieur
génial au milieu du vide intersidéral il
filera pas un iphone à chaque français
il peut pas donc en fait ce qu'on
appelle la technologie en fait c'est la
diffusion grâce à l'énergie du progrès
technique c'est bien ça qu'on appelle la
technologie et bien l'augmentation de
nos capacités extra corporelle grâce à
iron man nous a donné l'impression qu'on
pouvait maîtriser notre destin à des
échelles de temps très courte quelle que
soit la conséquence
malheureusement avec le changement
climatique c'est une illusion
c'est au delà de nos forces il faut
savoir que le supplément d'effet de
serre que nous avons déjà créé met en
jeu une énergie qui est déjà 100 fois
supérieure à celle qui est domestiqué
par les mains chine que les humains
utilisent déjà 100 fois supérieur
donc le processus ne sera pas maîtrisé
avec les bras les jambes et le même les
machines que nous utilisons sur terre il
ne sera pas maîtrisé avec ça il ya un
rapport de 1 à 100 c'est pas possible
donc pour le temps qu'il me reste à
vivre et pour le temps qu'il reste à
vivre à des enfants qui compte beaucoup
plus que vous non je plaisante donc tu
peux pas les machins et bien
malheureusement
vous eu jeu allons vivre dans un monde
dans lequel le climat ne sera plus
jamais stable
plus jamais
la stabilité climatique c'est ce qui a
permis la sédentarisation de notre
espèce ça faisait dix mille ans que le
climat était à peu près stable grâce à
quoi nous avons pu développer
l'agriculture parce que développer
l'agriculture dans un climat qui est
instable c'est quand même compliqué à
l'époque on laisse nos bras et aux
jambes si ça doit si ce qui pousse doit
changer tous les 50 ans ou les cent ans
vous avez pas l'inra et les tracteurs
pour corriger le tir
donc c'est ça qui a permis la
sédentarisation de notre espèce et
l'apparition lointaine de la
comptabilité pour compter les troupeaux
et les récoltes et donc l'apparition
récente de le scp qui hérite de cette
très très lointaine invention qui
s'appelle la comptabilité donc le la
stabilité climatique dont je leur dis
qu'ils aient perdu à jamais a été un
déterminant fondamental de la
sédentarisation de sociétés humaines
prospère
fondamentale
alors ici je vais aller rapidement
maintenant sur quelques
fonds rappelle parler rapidement de duck
est conséquente ici vous avez
l'évolution de passer des températures
de la température moyenne est de ce que
ça pourrait être à l'avenir en fonction
du scénario des missions et vous et que
même avec un scénario des missions de
type accords de paris en fait les trente
prochaines années sont à peu près celle
et donc l'évolution de la dérive
climatique pour les 30 prochaines années
elle est déjà inscrite
elle est déjà inscrite d'accord peut
plus rien y faire c'est après que ça se
joue alors pour voir si quelques degrés
c'est important ou pas il ya une
comparaison que j'aime beaucoup qui est
celle là ici vous avez les écosystèmes
installés en europe ya quelques siècles
alors en fait il ya quelques siècles on
va dire jusqu'à la révolution
industrielle à supposer qu'on ne les
supprime pas pour faire des choses
futiles comme deschamps ou essentiels
comme les locaux de scp donc on supprime
pas les écosystèmes installé nous avons
en europe essentiellement des forêts ça
veut dire que les conditions climatiques
sont suffisamment bonne il pleut
beaucoup en particulier en faillite peut
suffisamment effet ni trop chaud ni trop
froid pour qu'on ait des forêts
dans ce dans ce contexte là on peut
supprimer les forêts faire l'agriculture
voilà à quoi ressemble europe ya vingt
mille ans alors comme vous pouvez le
constater le paysage est un peu
différent d'abord erasmus en suède vous
oubliez il n'y a pas de suède puisque
donc lac va vite et pour les hommes les
suédoises terminée
la suède est recouvert d'un glacier de
trois kilomètres d'épaisseur comme la
finlande et la norvège du reste et comme
le nord de l'allemagne alors bonne
nouvelle pour les rugbymen français
c'est aussi le cas pour les écossais et
les irlandais
quand même quelque chose à prendre dans
cette affaire là
comme seka lot ont demandé beaucoup
d'eau pour être formés donc il ya une
énorme calotte glaciaire sur le nord de
l'europe il ya une chose sur le canada
le groenland a grossi et bien il ya eu
un énorme transfert d'eau de l'océan
versez calotte ce qu'il faut bien
prendre le départ comme pour faire des
glaçons et on a pris tellement d'eau
dans l'océan la nature a pris tellement
d'eau dans l'océan que le niveau de
l'océan a baissé de 120 m donc pas de
briques site puisqu'il ya la continuité
territoriale entre la france et la
grande bretagne
même pas de site ou en tout cas s'il ya
un break site ça pose pas de problème
aux ferries transmanche et pas de manche
et pas de paradis fiscaux non plus donc
il ya quelques personnes qui font de
l'optimisation fiscale peut-être chez
vos anciens lozériens qui sont au
chômage
vous avez un climat qui est beaucoup
plus froides ont beaucoup plus sec
puisque dans un climat froid
l'évaporation est beaucoup plus faible
et donc les précipitations beaucoup plus
faible et à ce moment pas question de
faire de l'agriculture une bonne partie
du sol européen et violé en permanence
est ce que vous avez en europe à ce
moment là ressemble à la végétation vous
trouvez aujourd'hui dans l'environnement
du renard arctique c'est à dire c'est de
la steppe type sibérienne et dans ce
genre d'environnement et bien ma foi
les effectifs
de la population française sont celles
d'un arrondissement lyonnais ou d'un
arrondissement parisien voilà ou d'un
art cinquième de l'agglomération
grenobloise
s'est pas beaucoup beaucoup de gens qui
sont capables de vivre dans cet
environnement là est bien quand la terre
s'est réchauffée pourrait que l'europe
est passée de ceux de cet état là à cet
état là dans le cadre de la dernière
déglaciation
l'évolution de la moyenne ça a été une
augmentation de 5 degrés en cinq à dix
mille ans donc là vous avez le résultat
d'une expérience grandeur nature qui a
été fait par la planète sans nous qui
consiste à réchauffer la température de
5 degrés en dix mille ans et vous voyez
le genre de transformations
environnementales que ça induit alors
maintenant je vais vous la faire brève
mais brahim est bonne comme disait
l'autre une élévation de température de
quelques degrés en un siècle en gros ça
sera la guerre partout ça sera une
déstabilisation des conditions qui était
stable depuis dix mille ans à une telle
vitesse
appliqué à une humanité sédentaires de
plusieurs milliards d'individus qui peut
pas facilement se déplacer en emportant
sur son dos les écoles les ponts et les
stations d'épuration pour aller au
demeurant se mettre ou soit c'est dans
un endroit où il ya déjà des écoles des
stations et des stations d'épuration et
des ponts et à ce moment vous avez aussi
des habitants qui sont pas du tout
contents de pouvoir arriver soit c'est
dans un endroit où il y à rien parce
qu'à pas d'habitants mais à ce moment
vous êtes à poil parce que vous avez ni
école ni station d'épuration nippon
et vous partez pas non plus en amenant
sur votre dos est très pop elle donc ce
que ce que ce que vous dit cette
évolution c'est qu'en fait le changement
climatique est en fait il ya énormément
d'exemple déjà documentés dans des
émeutes de la faim dans des dents
déstabilisation politique etc va être un
ferment majeur de dynamitage des
sociétés stables et prospères
et des sociétés instable et pas prospère
c'est des sociétés totalitaires
des sociétés instable et pas prospère
c'est des sociétés totalitaires donc le
changement climatique entre autres
choses si on laisse à son libre kouriles
dynamitera la démocratie
c'est absolument et la liberté
individuelle c'est absolument à nice est
absolument évident
voilà ça c'est des conséquences
évidemment qui sont pas des conséquences
physiques de premier ordre c'est celle
là que vous allez trouver dans les
rapports du giec mais c'est ma
conclusion comme disait l'autre
ou en tout cas c'est ce qui me paraît le
plus évident au regard de ce qui a été
l'histoire alors quand les économistes
s'attaque au problème qu'est ce qu'ils
disent eh ben ils disent n'importe quoi
pourquoi voulez vous qu'ils disent autre
chose que n'importe quoi puisque la
nature n'est pas dans les prix comme le
système climatique et gratuit par
convention
que vaut le dommage à un actif qui vaut
une traction 2 000 noms sauf erreur de
ma part donc à partir du moment où le
dommage à un actif vaut 1 0
comment est ce que vous voulez faire une
fonction de dommages dans un modèle
économique
bat à part faire comme ça bougeait pas
et donc vous allez trouver tout et
n'importe quoi dans le fait que les
dégâts par tonne de carbone émise se
trouve entre 10 $ et 600 mille dollars
tous dans la littérature économique tout
entre nordhaus qui a dit c'est pas la
peine de s'emmerder parce que de toute
façon la croissance perpétuelle fait
qu'avec changement climatique on est
juste deux pour cent moins riches à
l'arrivée une richesse qui a augmenté de
50 d'un facteur 50 par rapport à pas de
changement climatique donc je vais vous
trouvez du grand n'importe quoi de ce
type là mais c'est normal parce que
encore une fois c'est parce qu'en
revenant à la racine il n'existe pas de
manière de transcrire la physique dans
une fonction de dommages économiques
c'est impossible à cause de la
convention économique initiale qui est
que toute la nature vos héros c'est
impossible voilà s'amuser comme c'est
pas possible alors si on veut limiter le
réchauffement par contre il ya une
conséquence physique qu'il faut avoir en
tête afin 2000 alors pardon c'est pas
2018 et 2020 mais peu importe on avait
émis de l'ordre de 1300 milliards de
tonnes de co2 et sur cette courbe qui
vous donne la réponse en température en
fonction des émissions cumulées puisque
c'est les émissions cumulées qui compte
ça veut dire que nous avons déjà
réchauffer la planète d'un peu plus de
gras degrés
si on veut limiter à 2 degrés alors le
1° 5
et on va y arriver dans pas longtemps
donc il est déjà perdue si on veut
limiter à 2 degrés à ce moment apparent
je suis désolé le trail trop bas mais
c'est pas grave c'était parce que
j'étais mal réveillé dans le rer
eh bien il faut limiter alors aux
incertitudes de modélisation près il
faut limiter les émissions globales à
quelque chose entre 3000 et 4000
milliards de tonnes de co2
et ça quand vous regardez ce que ça
signifie en terme de traduction sur
l'évolution des émissions ça veut dire
que en gros il faut que les émissions se
mettent à baisser de 5% par an à partir
de maintenant alors 5% c'est ce qu'on a
eue l'année du coc vide en 2020 donc
rené cette conclusion très simple qui
est que pour lutter contre le changement
climatique dans les bon ordre de
grandeur il faut ralentir l'économie à
hauteur de 20 qu'ovide supplémentaires
supplémentaires par an
supplémentaire
c'est sa lutte et correctement contre le
changement climatique
vous voyez bien que pour le moment on se
paye de bon mot on n'est absolument pas
dans l'action à la hauteur et si la
personne qui a fait une introduction
vidéo était là je lui dirais exactement
ça et c'est exactement pareil à mon avis
pour ce qui se passe ici comme c'est
pareil pour ce qui se passe partout chez
les clients de carbone katché carbone va
partout pour le moment on n'est
absolument pas dans les clous en ce qui
concerne l'action qui va à la bonne
vitesse alors si on veut baisser les
émissions de 5 % par an il est utile de
savoir d'où elles viennent je vais vous
faire un panorama des émissions en 2019
je n'ai pas encore fait enfin j'aurais
pu actualiser pour 2020 ça change pas
beaucoup un cinquième des émissions
planétaires tout gaz à effet de serre
confondues donc là danger de co2 le
méthane et c'est assez les centrales à
charbon donc c'est évident qu'on a un
problème pour dézinguer les centrales à
charbon de la joe gibbs il ya des
questions j'y répondrai mais je vous en
parlerai je ne prononcerai qu'une fois
le mot nucléaire de la ma conviction qui
est que si on s'y prend en déployant des
éoliennes ça ira plus lentement que si
on s'y prend en déployant du nucléaire
donc ça veut dire que de choisir
l'option éolien ça veut dire choisir
perdre du temps et choisir perdre du
temps quand la course contre la montre
concerne le dynamitage de la démocratie
partout et le fait que les gens mangent
pas complètement sûr que ce soit la
bonne option mais voilà c'est ça ma
conviction
les centrales électriques à autres
combustibles fossiles essentiellement
gaz font 6 à 7% ce qui veut dire que si
vous regardez la production électrique à
combustible fossile on est aujourd'hui
sur un gros quart du problème donc
effectivement faut s'occuper de
l'électricité mais aussi occupé avec le
truc qui ira le plus vite pour dézinguer
le charbon parce qu'on est dans une
course contre la montre si vous avez le
choix parce que vous avez le cancer ce
que je ne vous souhaite pas entre un
anticancéreux efficaces qui va vous
faire perdre vos cheveux et de la poudre
de perlimpinpin qui vous gardera vos
cheveux si votre souci c'est vraiment de
traiter le cancer je vous conseille
l'anti cancéreux
donc le débat pour ou contre le
nucléaire s'inscrit bien dans cette dans
cette veine il s'inscrit pas dans la
veine d'un monde dans lequel on a le
choix le temps devant nous le temps de
faire et ses erreurs vingt-cinq fois et
la possibilité d'avoir des de faire de
faire un peu la fine bouche
parce que on crève de faim il ya un tout
petit peu trop de sel dans l'assiette
les cimenteries
sont aujourd'hui responsables de 7 % des
émissions mondiales c'est la première
industrie à part les centrales à charbon
émettrices de co2 dans le monde à ce qui
veut dire que la construction des villes
aujourd'hui ça fait plein de co2 parce
que il faut faire plein de ciment le
reste des émissions directes donc pas
l'électricité consommée mais les
émissions directes de l'industrie les
hauts fourneaux les feux les la chaleur
industrielle etc c'est 10% là dedans
vous avez encore 4% pour l'acier dont la
moitié sert aussi à faire des bâtiments
donc construire les villes j'y reviens
ça fait plein de co2
chauffer des bâtiments une fois
construit c'est patent dès missions que
ça en moyenne mondiale parce qu'il ya
plein droit on ne trouve pas vietnam en
sûr pas beaucoup dans le sud de la
californie non plus on a d'autres
problèmes
et puis vous avez dans les pays dans
lesquels c'est important souvent cette
part là qui est plus faible sur la
production électrique les transports ces
quatorze à quinze le parc mondial de
voitures c6 le parc mondial de camions
c4 et avant qu vide le parc mondial de
bateaux et d'avions ces deux donc là
vous avez toujours des ordres de
grandeurs voyez que la totalité des
transports c'est moins important que les
centrales à charbon donc oui il faut se
passer de bagnoles mais ça suffit pas il
faut se passer aussi de les construire
parce que l'acier effet au charbon
pas si simple
l'agriculture c'est 20% alors
l'agriculture c'est essentiellement des
gaz or co2 là dedans vous allez trouver
les rocard ellrott des vaches et les
paie car ils pètent des chevaux mais les
vaches fraude plus que les chevaux ne
pet dont vous allez trouver la
fermentation entérique des ruminants
vous allez trouver les émissions de
méthane des rizières vous allez trouver
les émanations de protoxyde d'azoté dans
les champs après l'épandage des engrais
azotés vous allez trouver éventuellement
les émanations de méthane est un peu de
protoxyde des fientes et des déjections
enfin bon voila vous trouvez tout un tas
de trucs là dedans 20% ça augmente à
mesure que nous consommons plus de
viande et vous avez un déterminant amont
de l'agriculture qui est la
déforestation donc la déforestation est
historiquement un processus par lequel
on coupe les forêts pour faire des
champs et ça ça à deux déterminants qui
sont la démographie et la consommation
de viande donc si on veut s'occuper
sérieusement de la déforestation j'ai
pas s'il faut donner au vvf mais il faut
donner au planning familial et aux gens
qui s'occupent de faire des recettes
savoureuses de pois chiches
c'est ça qui c'est ça qu'il faut faire
et enfin vous avez tout un tas d'autres
trucs d'opéra tôt d'autres poudre de
perlimpinpin vous avez la gestion des
déchets vous avez les fuites de fluides
frigorigènes
et donc choisis ton camp camarade il
faut que tout ça ça baisse de 5% par an
à partir de maintenant starting next
week voilà où sont vos business plan qui
sont compatibles avec ça
donc si le scp bête sérieuse je suis
désolé vous taquiner un peu mais enfin
je ne reviendrai pas ici demain matin il
faudrait qu'elle met une condition aux
limites à tout business plan produit par
tout étudiants de cette école c'est de
faire la démonstration que c'est
compatible avec une baisse de 5% par an
des émissions absolues de la planète
sinon 0
revoyez votre copie alors ça veut dire
deux choses ça ça veut dire que la
totalité des profs que le scp doivent
avoir compris le problème je suis pas
sûr que ce soit le cas et ensuite ça
veut dire que la totalité des élèves de
le scp doit avoir compris le problème ce
à quoi j'essaye de contribuer ce matin
et doivent l'avoir compris suffisamment
pour être capable de traduire ça dans un
business plan pour des vélos du
shampoing ou des services de garde
d'enfants à domicile
c'est ça la compétence qu'on vous
demande si vous voulez être en phase
avec la gestion de ce problème
c'est ça la compétence qu'on vous
demande
est de faire du contrat siège du lion
tfg pas quoi et de traiter des fonctions
d'utilité vous sera probablement pardon
pour la répétition d'une utilité très
secondaire
pour l'exposer que je viens de vous
donner alors là dedans l'énergie ça fait
deux tiers c'est pas la totalité donc il
ya encore beaucoup beaucoup d'émissions
qui viennent quand j deux tiers de ces
mêmes c'est même le co2 fait de tiers
l'énergie c'est plutôt 55 60 donc il ya
d'autres problèmes à régler que
l'énergie si on veut lutter contre le
changement climatique alors pour
l'énergie on entend souvent dire bon bah
écoutez c'est pas un problème on va la
passer à totalement en énergies
renouvelables alors j'ai une très bonne
nouvelle pour vous c'est possible est
possible comme disait l'autre dans le
dessin animé c'est possible voilà un
monde 100 % renouvelable donc c'est
possible pose aucun problème le monde en
zone 2 qui était celui des hommes et des
femmes jusqu'à ya deux siècles depuis
l'apparition de notre espèce a été 100 %
renouvelable
donc ça ne pose aucun problème de faire
un monde 100 % renouvelable aucun par
contre est ce que il est compatible avec
la hausse du cours de la bourse
d'essilor et l'existence d'un réseau
mcdonald's
- sur un ca c'est moins sûr mais c'est
possible ça ne pose strictement aucun
problème dans ce monde vous voyez la
batellerie et renouvelables les bateaux
sont en bois renouvelables poussé par
des bateliers renouvelables naviguant
sur des rivières renouvelables qui
alimente peut-être à laval un moulin
renouvelables avec une roue à aube en
bois renouvelables le vent renouvelables
pousse la marine marchande les chevaux
renouvelables mangent de l'herbe
renouvelables pour faire des transports
terrestres renouvelables les boeufs
renouvelables et qui du reste pouvait
être mangés en fin de vie tirs des
charrues en bois renouvelables tout ça
est renouvelable pose aucun problème
j'insiste aucun problème est-ce que 100%
d'énergies renouvelables est possible
dans le monde industriel que nous
connaissons aujourd'hui avec le parc de
machines qui démultiplient notre énergie
par deux sens alors là je parie toutes
mes économies contre toutes celles de
tout blanc fille et qui veut jamais de
la mine ça n'arrivera jamais on peut se
gargariser de discours ça n'arrivera
jamais
ja mais
encore une fois s'il ya des audacieux
qui les désolations ce qu'ils veulent
parier je prends les paris à la sortie
de l'amphi donc la question c'est quoi
la voie étroite entre ce qu'on arrive à
préserver est-ce qu'on n'arrive pas à
préserver
et jusqu'où on peut aller et c'est là
dedans qu'il est urgent de mettre du jus
de cerveau alors est-ce que le chemin
vers les renouvelables et celui que nous
empruntons même pas aujourd'hui si je
prends les vingt dernières années vous
voyez l'augmentation du charbon a été 7
fois plus importante que celle du
solaire est quatre fois plus importante
que celle de l'éolien sur les 20
dernières années donc depuis qu'il ya
des codes des machins des trucs et des
bidules
et en fait si je regarde les deux
derniers siècles on n'a fait que passer
des renouvelables au fossile donc on a
fait pour la marine marchande on l'a
fait pour les transports terrestres on
l'a fait pour l'agriculture on l'a fait
pour les travaux publics on l'a fait
pour l'industrie pour la construction
pardon on l'a fait pour l'industrie on
l'a même fait pour laisser choir luzerne
voilà un séchoir à l'usure de moderne
qui fonctionne au gaz
on l'a fait pour l'aviation on l'a même
fait pour la guerre rappelez-vous ce
bouquin de gaulle nous avons été vaincus
par une force face aux discours nous
avons été vaincus par une force
mécanique nous vaincrons par une force
mécanique supérieure en quantité mais
qu'est ce que c'est que la force
mécanique supérieure en quantité si ce
n'est des énergies
qui sont les deux grands gagnants de la
guerre de 39
l'urss
pour la russie et les etats unis c'est à
dire deux des trois plus gros producteur
de pétrole aujourd'hui états unis numéro
un et en russie numéro deux à parité
avec l'arabie saoudite c'est le pétrole
qui a gagné la guerre de 39-45 je vous
conseille cet excellent bouquin bordeaux
matthieu aux ados qui s'appelle or noir
dans lequel vous comprendrez qu'en fait
si la civilisation industrielle est né
il ya un siècle et non pas il ya 2000
ans alors qu'on connaît les énergies
renouvelables petit vent etc depuis deux
mille ans c'est bien qu'il ya une raison
physique c'est bien qu'il ya une raison
physique les gens étaient aussi
intelligent que vous et moi il ya deux
il ya 2000 ans vous savez archimède et
mozart étaient des génies absolue donc
léonard de vinci aussi donc pourquoi
est-ce qu'ils n'ont pas créée la
civilisation moderne tout simplement
parce que il n'y avait pas à l'époque la
possibilité de domestiquer cette énergie
fossile qui depuis a créé le monde
moderne
cette énergie fossile vous êtes assis
dessus
les fauteuils sur lesquels vous êtes à 6
et du pétrole les vêtements que vous
portez c'est du pétrole dès que vous
avez une fibre textile synthétique du
poly machin chouette du nil ont dû etc
pétrole le masque quand vous oblige à
porter je suis désolé pour vous mais moi
j'ai le privilège de cause et de ne pas
l'avoir du pétrole ce qui coiffe ce
micro du pétrole ce truc en plexiglas du
pétrole vous marchez sur du pétrole la
banquette c'est du pétrole tout à
l'heure à midi vous allez manger du
pétrole détracteurs des engrais des
camions qui ont regardé tout ça
jusqu'ici le shampoing du pétrole pour
lunettes du pétrole le vernis du pétrole
tout du pétrole d'accord tous les skis
parce que vous êtes privilégié que vous
avez les moyens moi aussi du pétrole
pour ceux d'entre vous qui cet été on
fait du parapente ou simplement sont
allés se balader en montagne avec des
adidas en faux ou n'importe quel autre
paire du pétrole
du pétrole partout du pétrole partout
absolument partout nous vivons dans une
baignoire de pétrole
ici vous avez des américains qui ont
sorti de leur domicile tout ce qui
comporte du pétrole comme molécule dans
la fabrication qui a plus rien et en
fait il aurait dû sortir le parquet si
les vernis puisque les vernis c'est du
pétrole il aurait dû enlever la peinture
c'est du pétrole enfin il oriente dû
enlever les canalisations en plastique
c'est du pétrole il ya du pétrole
partout et tout le temps du pétrole
alors le pétrole est stocké une voiture
balai
même si on se fout du climat qui est que
les gisements s'épuisent
vous trouverez dans un excellent travail
qui a été fait je n'insiste par le chief
project il ya six mois qui est passée
raisonnablement confidentiellement dans
la presse il ya l'ancien patron de
l'exploration de total donc celui qui
cherchait les gisements savait qu il
dénichait les autres paquets que sa
grosse loupe de sherlock holmes vous
avez le patron de l'évaluation des
gisements c'est à dire celui qui passe
derrière le premier en dix ans là dedans
je pense qu'on en y mettant en tant de
milliards on peut faire sortir tant de
pétrole
ces deux là fraîchement retraité ont
pris du service pour le chip project et
ils ont confirmé ce que l'agencé
internationale de l'énergie a dit en
2018 et qui devrait aussi occuper google
un peu plus que messi
ils ont dit la production de pétrole
conventionnel est passé par un maximum
en 2008 et décline depuis 2008 ça vous
rappelle rien dans le monde conomique
alors j'ai pas le temps de développer
aujourd'hui non plus mais la crise des
subprimes est avant tout une crise
énergétique la constitution des
subprimes est la conséquence cumulé
du de la décélération sur la production
de pétrole qui a suivi des chocs
pétroliers parce que l'endettement
croissant sadate des chocs pétroliers à
ce moment-là l'économie décélère et on
essaye de compenser avec des traits de
tirer sur l'avenir de façon croissante
et 2008 pic de production du
conventionnel deuxième coup de massue
derrière la nuque boom et depuis on voit
n'importe quoi les taux d'intérêts
négatifs le quantitatif à gogo enfin je
veux dire le tout ça est devenu une
espèce de grand n'importe quoi
et donc derrière vous allez retrouver le
pétrole est alors le pétrole va diminuer
à quelle vitesse il va diminuer voilà la
vitesse à laquelle il va diminuer pour
les 16 premiers fournisseurs de l'europe
c'est à dire la quasi totalité des pays
dans le monde qui sont des grands
fournisseurs de pétrole la russie a
passé son pic avant le kobe d'assaillir
ils ont annoncé les états unis
probablement ne reviendront pas à leur
niveau d'avant qu'ovide à cause du shale
oil qui enfin bon bref donc vous avez
encore l'irak qui peut beaucoup augmenté
mais sinon le comment l'afrique à passer
totalement son pic
la mer du nord évidemment enfin bon bref
la chine a passé son pic en 2015 donc
vous avez le mexique en 2004 enfin
maintenant la quasi totalité des grands
producteurs de brut dans la planète ont
passé leur pic et ici vous avez la
preuve la perspective qui a été publiée
par dechy project ça concerne tous les
pays du monde sauf un ou deux et ça
concerne pas l'europe lés pays en
question
par exemple le brésil ça fournit la
chine et les états unis n'est pas
l'europe et donc ce que vous voyez c'est
que de toute façon nous allons devoir
nous sevrer
même si
madame pompili et ses collègues ne font
rien
ou font des choses qui ne sont pas
utiles ce qui revient au même
le de toute façon nous allons devoir
nous en passer et à cause de
l'importance du pétrole encore
aujourd'hui dans l'économie ça veut dire
que le plus vraisemblable
je suis désolé de vous dire ça donc
c'est pour ça que c'est important de
faire des business plan qui s'inscrivent
dans ce cadre là le plus vraisemblable
c'est que l'essentiel de votre vie
future
s'inscrira dans un monde dans lequel la
crise économique sera le quotidien
c'est ça c'est ça que ça veut dire en
pratique et quand je dis vous moi aussi
un
voilà donc si vous étiez cohérent si
votre génération était cohérente elle
commençait par n'a pas payer les
retraites de la mienne
puisqu'on n'a pas fait grand chose alors
qu'on voyait voir on voyait venir ce
truc là pour faire en sorte que ça se
passe le moins mal possible
mais le voilà la situation donc en gros
si je résume et si je m'arrête là enfin
je m'arrête pas tout à fait là mais je
vais quand même résumé
nous sommes aujourd'hui pris en tenaille
entre deux risques qui se répondent
un risque de se confronter aux limites
planétaires parce qu'on ne se sèvrent
pas et un risque liés au sevrage qu'ici
on l'effectué doit s'effectuer à une
vitesse telle que ça ressemble pas à
rentrer dans le mur à pleine vitesse
mais ça ressemble quand même à décélérer
en faisant quelques tonneaux
c'est ça la situation dans laquelle on
est et aussi je le redis autrement ça
veut dire qu'on va devoir gérer plus
d'environnement avec moins de moyens
et plus on attend pour vous demander de
faire des business plans compatible avec
ça
et plus au moment où ça se produit on
saura dans une situation où le marteau
va taper fort sur l'enclume
alors on pas qu'on vous a déjà cité cet
homme donc je vais finir de me fâcher
avec vos profs d'économie je vais
commencer enfin je vais finir par là où
j'ai commencé
en gros l'économie qu'on vous apprend
aujourd'hui elle dérive de façon très
sophistiquée avec des tas de fonctions
de mathématiques complexes etc auxquels
je ne comprends rien mais elles dérivent
de manière très ancien fan de badens de
manière très sophistiqué d'un postulat
très ancien qui est que pour alimenter
le système productif j'ai besoin de deux
facteurs humains qui sont le capital et
le travail et ça ça suffit à remplir le
supermarché
alors en fait l'ingénieur qui regarde ça
il vous dit où c'est pas sûr parce que
pour remplir le supermarché il faut
avoir la matière qui va remplir le
supermarché donc en fait si vous voulez
faire une chemise c'est compliqué sans
les molécules qui constitue la chemise
vous n'êtes pas venus ce matin habillé
avec un concept de vêtements en étant en
pratique à poil en plus la loi
l'interdît et
même si la température aujourd'hui s'y
prêterait donc vous êtes venus avec des
vrais vêtements constitué de vrai at
home et devrait molécules il a bien
fallu les trouver quelque part d'accor
donc pour avoir une production et c'est
vrai même dans les services voyez
l'enseignement est un service mais pour
le signer le service d'enseignement dans
lequel vous êtes il faut faire cet amphi
avec du pétrole partout comme je vous
l'aï dit tout à l'heure il faut que je
sois capable de venir ici pour causer
dans un rer qui est faite du fer et du
plastique c'est à dire encore du pétrole
il faut que l'on soit alimenté en
électricité parce que sinon je suis
obligé de me promener et puis vous avez
pas droit mais planche qui sont quand
même merveilleuse même si on m'a dit
qu'elle était ringarde voilà comme je
suis vieux maintenant on la change pas
donc le mais vous êtes donc en fait on a
besoin même dans les services de flux
physiques
et de matières même dans les services on
a besoin de ça dont vous avez besoin
quelle que soit la production économique
que vous regardez de ressources
naturelles et vous avez besoin d'une
capacité à les transformer est ce que je
vous ai expliqué tout à l'heure c'est
que cette capacité à les transformer
c'est un peu nous essentiellement les
machines et l'énergie voilà c'est ça la
réalité du système productif et si vous
avez un stress sur l'approvisionnement
énergétique qu'ils soient voulus pour
raisons climatiques
ou subie pour raisons géologiques peu
importe la conséquence économique est la
même vous avez un stress sur le flux
physiques de production et donc vous
avez un pib qui morfle
avec un rapport de un à deux sens entre
les machines et les individus c'est
juste pas possible qu'il en soit
autrement
l'aco variations que je vous ai montré
tout à l'heure entre le volume de
pétrole et le pib par personne
c'est logique et si vous avez un stress
sur les ressources naturelles par
exemple n'avait plus assez de sable pour
faire du béton
si vous n'avez plus assez de sable pour
faire du béton vous oubliez la
construction des mille
parce que par ailleurs vous n'aurez pas
assez de bois pour faire la totalité du
flux constructif qu'on a aujourd'hui en
bois ça pousse pas assez vite s'il n'y a
pas assez de surface on est trop
nombreux on a besoin du reste pour
l'agriculture et certains entre d'entre
nous considèrent que c'est aussi bien de
l'avoir pour les orangs outans où les
rossignols peu importe et c'est la
raison pour laquelle l'europe a sorti il
n'ya pas longtemps ce document que je
vous invite à lire alors l'european
variante agency est une institution
officielle de l'union - comme la cour de
justice ou la commission donc c'est pas
une ong et elle a sorti au moment où un
van der leyen aller expliqué partout
qu'on allait faire le green deal c'est à
dire la croissance verte ils ont sorti
un papier en disant eux c'est pas sûr
enfin ça sera peut-être games sas a pas
de la croissance
ça pose un tout petit problème dans
l'attelage dans lequel nous vivons parce
que je vous rappelle que l'article 3 du
traité de lisbonne dit que l'europe vise
la croissance
c'est quand même ballot d'avoir dans la
constitution un truc qu'on n'est pas sûr
d'avoir et non seulement qu'on n'est pas
sûr d'avoir mais qu'on est de plus en
plus sûrs de ne pas avoir au fil du
temps voilà donc et je vais finir par ça
la totalité des modèles macroéconomiques
que j'ai regardé jusqu'à maintenant je
ne sais pas si vous le saviez sinon je
voudrais voir un an après quelque chose
on une croissance du pib qui est exogène
c'est pas le résultat de la simulation
c'est une hypothèse poser a priori et la
seule chose que fait le modèle c'est
kivu module la croissance qui est
supposé exogènes a priori en fonction
des hypothèses que vous allez mettre
dans votre modèle je taxe un peu plus
les riches un peu moins les riches
mais mais en fait ça ne l'hypothèse de
départ elle est exogène c'est à dire que
le modélisateur a dit de toute façon il
y aura de la croissance et vous n'avez
pas aujourd'hui sauf erreur de ma part
jamais vu ça
deux courants mainstream de la
littérature
économique
dans lequel les gens postule que le pib
va décroître smm vrai dans les modèles
intégrée comportant le climat pour avoir
discuté avec des gens qui manipulent ce
genre de modèle alors si c'est pas le
pib qui croissent et la productivité du
travail qui croient indéfiniment ce qui
revient exactement au même mais à quoi
est due la productivité du travail sist
et aux machines et à l'énergie
à quoi il nous a pas poussé 50 bras et
42 jambes pour augmenter la production
par personne c'est pas ça qui s'est
passé voilà donc j'ai dépassé de dix
minutes suis vraiment désolé
et donc maintenant je suis disponible
pour les questions j'insiste vraiment
sur un point c'est que si vous êtes
sérieux sur le problème que je viens
d'évoquer vous allez devoir prendre
beaucoup beaucoup de distance et vous
posez beaucoup beaucoup de questions sur
ce que vous allez apprendre ici
merci
[Applaudissements]
merci monsieur jean collet si pour cet
exposé qui était véritablement édifiant
on va maintenant passer en tant de
questions de l'association tribune puis
un temps de questions des élèves donc
réfléchissez bien à vos questions
je vais commencer par une question qu'on
vous a sans doute beaucoup posé mais que
beaucoup j'imagine ici trouvent flou
c'est le thème de l'hydrogène vous
critiquez souvent l'hydrogène comme
étant une fausse solution ou étant
inefficaces or on parle déjà de voitures
en bardella de voitures et même d'avion
qui fonctionnerait à l'hydrogène qui ne
rejetterait aucun gaz à effet de serre
et selon de la vapeur d'eau pourquoi
selon vous alors l'hydrogène n'est-il
pas une solution viable et surtout de
quoi cet engouement autour d'une
solution qui n'est pas forcément une
est-il symptomatique
j'ai deux heures et vous ramassez la
copie parce qu'il ya 25 questions là
dedans
[Musique]
alors dans les réponses que je vais
faire la première c'est que pour savoir
si quelque chose est une marge de
manoeuvre significative ou pas il faut
faire des calculs
c'est pas la même chose que de dire on
sait faire un avion à hydrogène qui dans
lequel on pourra voler avec un billet
qui vaut 25 fois
le prix que parce que blue origin là qui
est allé balader bezeau c'est son frère
dans l'espace c'est un avion hydrogène
un peu particulier mais enfin c'est un
avion hydrogène mais c'est pas le même
prix c'est pas à bratislava pour 30euros
quoi
donc le donc l'hydrogène en fait les
gens qui en font la promotion confondent
un emile et la presse confond à emile
donc en fait le vrai débat c'est de
faire la différence entre un email
deuxième chose de l'hydrogène c'est
l'élément le plus abondant qu'on trouve
sur terre je vous ai dit tout à l'heure
que il était associé sur terre à
l'oxygène pour former un oxyde qui était
présent sous forme d oxyde depuis des
milliards d'années donc pour disposer de
l'hydrogène il faut toujours le séparait
de l'élément auquel il est associé il
est jamais il est exceptionnellement
libre et pour ce faire vous allez devoir
utiliser plus d'énergie que l'hydrogène
vous en restituera quand vous en
servirez donc ça laisse le problème
entier il faut trouver cette énergie ne
peut pas être une énergie c'est un
vecteur
il ne veut pas émettre zéro co2
puisqu'il émet autant de co2 que celui
que vous avez émis pour sa production
son transport et l'appareil qui va s'en
servir donc zéro co2 dans le monde
aujourd'hui ça n'existe nulle part donc
dès que vous voyez zéro co2 est sûr
c'est du bullshit je vous ai pas fait
aujourd'hui le petit traité du bullshit
j'aurais pu donc quand des gens vous
disent qu'ils sont d'autres c'est du
bullshit quand ils vous disent qu'ils
sont verts c'est du bullshit quand ils
vous disent que c'est zéro co2 c'est du
bullshit donc après la seule bonne
question c'est de savoir où
dès que vous voyez ce genre
d'affirmation si vous êtes un peu
curieux vous avez un peu de temps que ce
genre de sujet vous intéresse creusez
vous la cervelle pour savoir où il loue
baisser la seule question à se poser
aujourd'hui d'hydrogène on sait en faire
sur terre on en fait avec dur formage
d'hydrocarbures donc ce qu'on fait c'est
qu'on prend des hydrocarbures souvent du
gaz on mélange à de la vapeur d'eau on
met ça dans une grosse cocotte minute
sous pression et on chauffe très fort
résultat des courses c'est au moins dix
tonnes de co2 par tonne d'hydrogène
toujours résultat des courses
aujourd'hui une voiture à pile à
combustible qui utiliserait de
l'hydrogène produit de cette manière
émet plus de co2 qu'une voiture à
essence donc c'est pas du tout zéro co2
c'est zéro co2 parce que des
journalistes qui passe les plats relais
des communiqués de presse de boîte qui
ne sont pas punis quand elles mentent
je lui ai dit tout à l'heure j'ai
démarré parce à mentir sur la physique
n'est pas illégal
ça n'est pas illégal ça rentre dans la
liberté d'expression
donc vous pouvez racontais toutes les
conneries que vous voulez sur la
physique personne ne vous tapera sur les
doigts pour sa personne enfin pas le
juge
donc le
là il ya un article de loi qui a essayé
de lutter contre ça dans la loi climat
m'enfin bon et qui a été beaucoup
commandé par le bo coûte édulcoré pardon
par ses divers passages à l'assemblée
l'article de loi devait dire que se
revendiquer de la neutralité est est
illégale voilà mais finalement ça s'est
passé donc c'est que le bullshit et
encore de beaux jours devant lui le
camp vous que quand on fait des calculs
de grandeur je vous en donner un qui
vaut ce qu'il vaut si on voulait en
france remplacer les carburants routiers
par de l'hydrogène il faudrait doubler
le parc électrique pour produire
l'hydrogène en question il faudrait
construire un réseau de gaz
distinct de celui que nous avons
aujourd'hui parce que l'hydrogène étant
la plus petites molécules gazeuses qui
existe sur terre l'hydrogène est très
diffuses il va se coller des vous avez
une microfissure etc et vous pouvez pas
utiliser le réseau de grdf actuelle pour
pour l'hydrogène parce que c'est ça
fragilise l'acier ou l'hydrogène la
semaine dans les microfissures etc
donc quand vous regardez en fait les
barrières à franchir pour arriver à ce
fameux d'hydrogène sans co2 etc il
faudrait construire une énorme quantité
de réacteurs nucléaires parce qu'avec
des éoliennes vous allez rien il ya des
gens qui sont vantés dans ouest-france
avoir fait un peu d'hydrogène mais c'est
toujours pareil quand vous regardez les
ordres de grandeur c'est comme si
renault se vantait de vendre plus de
trombone pour compenser la perte de
ventes de voitures je lis vol mais enfin
c'est pas exactement ça qui va faire le
job donc il faut regarder les chiffres
et quand vous regardez les chiffres vous
arrivé à la conclusion que ça sera un
déterminant tout à fait secondaire les
seules applications éventuellement
intéressante de l'hydrogène sont dans
l'industrie et j'en vois deux compte
tenu des volumes et des ordres de
grandeurs ça consisterait à construire
des réacteurs nucléaires dédié à
l'électrolysé de l'eau en permanence et
à utiliser mettre ça au cul
d'un haut fourneau en plaçant le haut
fourneau donc pour faire de la réduction
du minerai de fer et de l'acier ce que
je vous ai dit que le pétrole était
partout et l'acier est partout aussi
vous êtes associé vous êtes aussi assis
sur d'acier vous êtes aussi venu ici
avec de l'acier ça l'est aussi manger
quand cette d'acier et enfin vous aurez
donc vous avez la réduction du minerai
de fer l'hydrogène qui est un truc où
les volumes sont à peu près du bonheur
de grandeur et la fabrication des
engrais parce que même si on n'aime pas
l'agriculture intensive on a tellement
défoncé les sols plats des terres
qu'aujourd'hui si on voulait revenir à
de l'agriculture sans engrais
assez vite on aurait des productions
végétales qui serait divisé par cinq
il ya les plus beaux lots essayer de
mettre progressivement et j'en suis un
grand militant en route un certain
nombre de mesures qui me paraissent
pertinentes
varier les cultures avec des armes mais
on se passera quand même pas d'engrais
demain matin même si on mange moins de
viande et donc
l'hydrogène c'est le constituant
principal de la fabrication de
l'ammoniac et l'ammoniac et le état est
un est un précurseur important de la
chimie les engrais azotés donc là
boîtier l'hydrogène qu'on fabrique
aujourd'hui dans le monde sert à faire
des engrais azotés
donc voilà donc quand on regarde un peu
les chiffres on se rend compte que
l'hydrogène ne servira pas à faire des
avions zéro co2 et en plus manger c'est
quand même plus important que de prendre
l'avion même si on va beaucoup vous
inciter à le faire et
donc le transport aérien de masse c'est
bien il est né avec le pétrole est il
mort avec le pétrole il faut envisager
l'avenir
en comprenant bien que c'est comme ça
que ça va se passer
merci une question concernant votre
activité cabinet de conseil carbone 4
vous en parliez tout à l'heure de vos
clients de carbone 4 qu'ils ne sont même
parfois pas forcément réglo et donc qui
ne suivent pas forcément vos conseils au
cours des dernières années observé vous
dans votre activité une évolution
concrète de la demande des entreprises
que vous conseiller et non ce qu'on
constate c'est avant même de savoir si
elle est concrète on constate une
évolution de la demande
donc il est clair qu'en ce moment
carbone 4 est dans la situation très
confortable et très enviable nous avons
du mal à répondre à la demande qui
augmente très fort quand on a créé
carbone 4 on s'est toujours dit faire
car enfin comment dire viser la
croissance pour la croissance ça nous
intéresse pas et du reste on continue à
dire que ça nous intéresse pas il se
trouve cependant que en ce moment on a
une demande qui augmente extrait très
extrêmement rapidement vraiment vraiment
très fortement alors qu'un putt 4 ne
fait pas que du conseil aujourd'hui
carbone4 fait également fournit
également de la donner pour le secteur
financier et alors là c'est une autre
paire de manches parce que le secteur
financier en est là où étaient les
entreprises ya 20 ans donc dans une dent
dans une espèce de grande bouillie pour
chat dans lequel
n'importe quelle méthode fait le job
pourvu qu'on dit qu'on a fait quelque
chose
alors qu'en fait l'essentiel des
méthodes utilisées par le secteur
financier relève du greenwashing aussi
dans lequel la compréhension du problème
à traiter est beaucoup trop parcellaires
compte tenu de voilà donc on a on a
aussi une activité en croissance
significative dans le domaine financier
mais c'est un secteur qui est
aujourd'hui moins confortable
là dans l'exercice et puis par ailleurs
j'ai découvert les financiers étaient
les plus pingres de tous les acheteurs
plus on gagne de pognon plus on n'est
pas quand finalement l'allégorie de
picsou et pas complètement est pas
complètement vaine
donc le
pour parvenir à carbone 4 ce qu'ont
constaté une augmentation de la demande
la deuxième chose que je pense qu'on
constate c'est qu'il ya un nombre
croissant d'individus qui bascule c'est
à dire qu'il ya un nombre croissant
d'individus qui sont à titre personnel
convaincu qu'il faut faire quelque chose
et quelques choses en grand même s'ils
n'ont pas les idées claires ce qui
manque encore aujourd'hui c'est de voir
des organisations basculer
alors quand je dis de voir des
organisations basculé il y en a qui
bascule dans le discours il y en a même
qui bascule dans une partie
significative de leurs actes mais à
l'échelle de l'ensemble de l'économie on
est encore très très loin du compte donc
il ya des organisations est en fait
l'innovation comme souvent alors ça
c'est un des trucs juste qu'on va vous
apprendre l'innovation comme souvent
elle vient des challengers c'est à dire
elle vient des gens qui sont petit par
rapport à la taille du système donc les
gens qui sont dominants sur leurs
marchés ont énormément de mal à être en
rupture et en plus pas du tout leurs
intérêts
l'innovation et bien et bien souvent
général des challengers
alors les challengers peuvent être de
nature ça peut être des entités d'un
grand groupe à qui on a foutu la paix on
les laisse faire exactement ce qu'ils
veulent dans leur coin et le business
qui le développe n'est pas antagoniste
avec celui des autres activités ou bien
on peut avoir des pme pays qui ont déjà
quelques moyens mais qui sont encore
mobile qui se mettent à envisager de
changer significativement
la façon dont elles dont elle s'exerce
cela étant il faut bien voir qu'une
entreprise à l'échelle individuelle
c'est toujours un projet de croissance
au sens de des gens qui se disent je
vais sereinement envisager que mon
avenir soit une contraction de
l'activité
à part car 24 les personnages hip hop
hardcore cas parce que moi je dis
toujours à mes collaborateurs car 24 est
une société qui a vocation à s'auto
dissoudre le jouerons le prêt du
changement climatique sera réglé et à ce
moment vous pourrez mettre sur votre cv
à contribuer à sauver le monde et je ne
doute pas que vous trouverez un autre
patron ailleurs facilement donc le voile
avait cessé
c'est quelque chose qui est compliqué à
faire passer dans l'économie parce qu'en
pratique si on veut être sérieux une
partie des activités actuelles devant
disparaître
et ça pose toute la question de la
reconversion de et c'est ce que font les
gens qui sont est-ce que le flux naturel
de sortie est suffisant est-ce qu'il
faut les faire sortir un peu plus vite
alors on s'y attaque pas car 24 à cette
question mais on est en train de s'y
attaquer aux chiffres project dans le
cadre du plan de transformation de
l'économie française sur lequel on
travaille d'arrache-pied en vue des
présidentielles
justement parlant de plan de
transformation de l'économie française
de challenger je me posais une question
sur l'offre politique en matière
d'écologie et du climat il ya quelques
années vous déploriez justement le
manque crucial d'une offre politique
concrètes et sérieuses en cette matière
est ce qu'aujourd'hui à huit mois des
élections présidentielles vous allez
impression qu une offre sérieuse
commencé à émerger que ce soit chez les
candidats qui ne se sont pas déjà
présentés ou alors pour ceux qui se sont
déjà présentés ou est-ce qu'on reste
globalement dans des slogans de
greenwashing
alors la réponse est courte et non
la réponse un peu plus longue c'est que
le sérieux j'ai l'impression si je veux
être un peu nuancé qui vient de la base
enfin qu'il est remontant le sérieux
c'est à dire qu'on va trouver on
commence à trouver aujourd'hui
au sein des élus locaux
qui est une galaxie dans laquelle et à
boire et à manger on commence à trouver
des gens qui essayent vraiment
sincèrement de faire les choses un peu
en grand j'ai envie de dire ça on
commence à trouver
alors ils vont pas encore jusqu'au bout
de la logique mais bon il essaye on va
dire plus plus sérieusement au niveau
des élus nationaux ça reste on reste
pris dans les injonctions
contradictoires de façon massive mais y
compris chez les verts
qui n'ont pas les mêmes contradictions
que les autres mes clients n'ont quand
même je vais vous en citer deux et à
dessein je vais pas vous citer celle à
laquelle vous pensez la première
contradiction c'est l'augmentation du
pouvoir d'achat et la baisse de la
pression environnementale partir du
moment où l'augmentation du pouvoir
d'achat c'est une conséquence directe de
l'augmentation du pib et que augmentait
de pib en baissant la pression
environnementale c'est pas possible
les partis dits de gauche et les verts
se considère comme un parti de gauche
ils sont pris dans cette contradiction
qui est plus pour tous enfin un peu
moins pour bernard nadeau pour bernard
arnault mais ça ne suffit pas à donner
plus à tous les autres
donc plus pour tous et et moins et moins
de pression environnementale dans les
ordres de grandeur qui sont nécessaires
et que j'ai évoqué tout à l'heure ça
malheureusement
ça ne marche pas
la deuxième chose
le deuxième exemple que je pourrais
citer
c'est que dans la mouvance écologiste
traditionnels on envisage un monde dans
lequel les ressources sont plus rares en
toute bonne logique ça devrait conduire
à envisager un monde dans lequel
les tensions vont être plus importante
et en général c'est des partis qui
prônent le fait de ne pas se préoccuper
des futures tensions en par exemple en
se préoccupant pas d'armé en se
préoccupant pas de guerre etc je pense
aussi que c'est une forme de naïveté
d'accord je pense que dans un monde dans
lequel les tensions vont augmenter on va
quand même malheureusement être obligé
de parler un peu d'années et de parler
un peu de ce genre de choses donc voilà
voilà deux exemples et encore une fois
j'ai pas citer celui auquel vous pensiez
délibérément pour lequel je ne vois pas
les verts comme étant comme ayant une
cohérence interne sur ce sujet là qui
est plus développée
par contre quand vous quittez la
politique nationale et que vous n'avez
pas à vous soucier ni de géopolitique ni
de force militaire ni de pib dans son
ensemble et que vous tombez sur je dois
me soucier de faire des pistes cyclables
d'essayer de modifier le rendu des
cantines d'inciter les gens à rénover
leur logement les inciter à moins
consommer à plus réparer de favoriser la
création d'ateliers de réparation etc
là vous voyez arriver des gens qui ont
une cohérence interne plus être plus
élevé voilà c'est ça le ils sont encore
très très parcellaire il faut bien les
chercher avec une grosse loupe mais on
commence à en voir
d'accord merci beaucoup je vais devoir
finir montant de questions à moi parce
qu'il faut passer aux questions du
public et des élèves à présent donc ne
soyez pas timide on va vous passer le
micro vous n'avez qu'à lever la main
je fais le chameau pour le moment
il me semble que quelqu'un
d'administration avait été désigné aussi
pour poser des questions
sinon je sais pas où je crois je crois
que la main la plus rapide était à ma
droite là
[Musique]
je suis désolé c'est bien la preuve que
ce que j sert à rien
en fait désolé pour moi
j'ai cru comprendre avec votre
présentation qu'en fait l'augmentation
des températures à court terme en fait
c'était déjà joué et donc ce que enfin
donc j'ai compris l'enjeu enfin je pense
avoir compris les enjeux futurs que vous
nous avez présenté mais alors qu'est ce
qu'on peut faire à l'échelle personnel
en sortant de s&p en fait puisque la
finance le conseil tout ça ça nous ouvre
grand les bras
qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire nous à notre
échelle et au delà de ça pour quoi en
fait sachant que vous venez de nous
présenter comme des scénarii
catastrophiques
bonne question comme dirait l'autre
je vais essayer là aussi je suis désolé
je fais souvent des réponses manga mais
c'est
vous pouvez faire plusieurs choses la
première chose c'est que pendant votre
scolarité à le scp vous pouvez essayer
de vous documenter
auprès de sources crédibles et donc je
pourrais vous faire un long
développement sur comment est ce qu'on
fait la différence entre le premier site
internet qui passaient une source
crédible
sur ce que j'ai évoquée dès lors que ça
se trouvera pas dans vos programmes
o'shea project on a fait il ya quelques
années un projet qui s'appelle climat
sub
et alors c'est pas avec l'ocp qu'on
démarre je suis désolé on va démarrer
avec audencia mais on va faire un pilote
mais ensuite la méthode sera disponible
pour tout le monde pour essayer de
comprendre comment est ce que dans une
école de commerce on peut rendre le
sujet que je viens d'évoquer compatible
avec la totalité de l'enseignement donc
en fait c'est ça la question qu'est ce
que ça veut dire sur la structure des
programmes le corps enseignant ce que
doivent faire les élèves etc comme vous
ne serez pas dans ce contexte là d'un
obstant l'intention très louable qui a
été évoqué tout à l'heure ça veut dire
que vous allez devoir trouver une partie
de l'information complémentaire à
l'extérieur donc la première mauvaise
nouvelle c'est que vous allez devoir
crier un peu moins fort pendant les
soirées
et enfin si vous irez toujours en soirée
mais passer un peu de temps dans la
journée à essayer de compléter ce qu'on
va vous apprendre ici sur la finance
magna les pins pee wee de problèmes aux
mines où j'enseigne en l'espace de
quelques années les grands groupes ils
sont passés de ceux des deux tiers de la
promo à 25%
n'y allez pas voilà c'est aussi bête que
ça le conseil c'est pareil il ya les
parle alors la question c'est qu'est ce
que enfin en tout cas pas chez les gens
vous pouvez aller dans des petites
structures qui vont être des pure
players de ce genre de problème ça vous
en trouvez
du reste on a quelques alors les c'est
que je crois c'est plus plus revu avant
vous je suis de dire ça à carbonne
carton à quelques essais qu'on n'a pas
de laisser des mets donc mais c'est des
gens qui ont complété leur cursus par
des informations là-dessus et qui ont
qui se sont fait lors leur vision
cohérente
sur le sujet et qui ont commencé à
maturer leurs réflexions sur le business
et ce sujet avant de rentrer chez nous
et on n'est pas les seuls je veux dire
on a des confrères des concurrents comme
vous voulez
et vous avez quelques années pour vous
faire une idée sur où sont les
employeurs possible de gens qui ont
envie de s'agiter un peu sur ce genre de
sujet
normalement puisque sauf erreur de ma
part j'ai compris que vous rentriez tout
juste
sauvegarde thermonucléaire vous avez
trois ans pour essayer de vous faire une
petite idée sur la question
voilà quelques voilà quelques éléments
de réponse
au moins vous avez la chance par rapport
à vos anciens
éventuellement d'avoir décidé dès le
début de vos études
quels secteurs dans quel secteur vous
n'iriez pas ce qui vous permet quand
même de disposer d'un peu de temps pour
travailler là où vous pourriez aller
une autre question
bonjour j'ai une question concernant le
développement en fait donc vous dites
que la hausse du pouvoir d'achat est
incompatible avec la baisse de la
pression environnementale or il ya des
pays dans lesquels le niveau de vie et
faible et il ya des situations de vie
qui sont indécentes pardon de comment
est il possible en fait de permettre à
tout le monde de disposer d'un niveau de
vie décent tout en les mettant la
pression environnementale alors c'est un
problème un des merdes abl parce qu'il
faut se mettre d'accord sur ce que
signifie descendent
quand on regarde l'espérance de vie à la
naissance aujourd'hui alors je sais ce
que je vais vous dire ne le
des porteurs d'aucune connotation morale
dans les pays qu'on appelle en
développement que quand j'étais jeune on
appelait très sympathiquement sous
développés
c'est très très supérieur à ce qui était
l'espérance de vie à la naissance d'un
français ya deux siècles très supérieure
l'espérance de vie à la naissance en
inde par exemple
elle est supérieure à 60 ans l'espérance
de vie à la naissance en france en 1907
et 49 ans et l'espérance de vie à la
naissance en france en 1800 c'était un
peu plus de 20 en ville parce qu'à
l'époque en ville il n'y avait pas de
structure hospitalière et pas
d'antibiotiques par contre y avait la
concentration de bias et tous les gens
qui faisaient qu'à côté des puits et les
épidémies qui se propageaient facilement
et elle était d'un peu moins de 30 ans à
la campagne
donc question par exemple c'est quoi une
espérance de vie décentes est-ce que
c'est celle qu'on a aujourd'hui qu'on
doit garder 80 ans est-ce que c'est
celle d'il ya deux siècles parce que ça
a toujours été celle là trente ans est
ce que c'est quelque chose entre les
deux si c'est entre les deux c'est 45
ans oui alors c'est horrible cette la
manière dont je suis en train de poser
la question mais c'est juste pour dire
on a énormément de mal à
se mettre d'accord sur
données un contenu normatif à des termes
qui n'en n'ont pas je vais donner un
deuxième exemple est ce qu'à un niveau
de vie décent pour des gens qui n'ont
pas de voiture
c'est avoir un âne et une carriole c'est
avoir un vélo ou c'est avoir une voiture
pour des gens qui n'ont rien de tout ça
vous savez répondre à la question moi
j'étais pas donc c'est la grande
difficulté elle est là alors ce que je
sais c'est que c'est physiquement
impossible
je vais dire un truc qui va peut-être
vous faire sauter en l'air mais c'est
physiquement impossible que de manière
durable la totalité des africains et la
possibilité de consommer matériellement
comme un occidental d'aujourd'hui et je
m'apprête à dire exactement la même
chose j'ai été invité à faire une
intervention que j'aurai plaisir à
entrer qui s'appelle la french-american
à la french american foundation
où il ya une proposition de sang hyun
leader devant lesquels on me propose de
causer et alors quand je regarde ce
qu'ils font c'est que des gens qui vont
copier le modèle occidental en afrique
c'est des managers d'orange de l'oréal
ne sais pas quoi pour des zones
africaines donc ils sont en train de
faire exactement la connerie qu'il
faudrait pas faire parce que exactement
ce que je vais aller leur dire parce que
ça passera pas parce que ça passera pas
malheureusement donc quand on sait que
ça passera pas il vaut mieux passer son
temps à faire autre chose je veux dire
moi je peux battre des je peux battre
des bras pendant un siècle devant vous
je voudrais pas pour autant bon donc
peut-être qu'il faut que j'essaye de ne
pas passer mon temps à essayer de voler
en battant des bras j'essaye de faire
autre chose je vais pas en mourir tout
de suite du reste si je ne peux pas
voler en battant des bras mais je vais
juste perds mon temps
donc il ya un
manque aujourd'hui de débats pour se
mettre d'accord sur c'est quoi un bon
point de convergence
réaliste alors est ce que dans ce monde
là dans ce monde-là faut qu'on soit
logique par ailleurs tous les français
qui disent ah ah ah le droit au
développement des africains s'ils sont
cohérents avec même ici de la moitié de
ce qu'ils ont un parce que le point de
convergence se fera en sous
du pouvoir d'achat matériel d'un
français d'aujourd'hui
bah oui c'est très très clair donc là
aussi la quasi totalité des gens qui
lisent moi je voudrais que en fait ils
sont ils sont pas compatibles avec les
limites planétaires et les implications
de ces limites planétaires voilà c'est
ça le la triste vérité alors comment est
ce qu'on y arrive je veux finir ma
réponse part ça on n'y arrivera pas
théoriquement grand creux sans y mettre
beaucoup de jus de cerveau aujourd'hui
on ne réfléchit même pas la question et
on se compare sur le présupposé
absolument évident que il suffit
d'envoyer nos à chausser de scp en
afrique et un jour tous les africains
ils ont une voiture
moi je crois que c'est pas ça qui va se
passer et donc il faudrait qu'on parte
sur des présupposés qui sont les bons
c'est à dire qui a des limites et que
on essaye d'éviter
plutôt des cas de figure comme la syrie
ou d'autres d'autres cas de figure de
cette nature qui sont plutôt
malheureusement à mon avis en tendance
longue ce qui attend les systèmes dans
l'impasse
mais ce monsieur nous avons passé une
dernière question de l'amphithéâtre
gélis
un autre avis
d'accord
alors on n'entend pas le
e-commerce
quelle place aux étudiants en école de
commerce à ce que les connaissances
techniques doivent prendre sachant que
le modèle vous propose essentiellement
physique
[Musique]
supérieure
ça doit prendre une place supérieure
le
c'est exactement la question en fait
qu'on a on va se poser dans la
collaboration qui a entre le chi project
et audencia
c'est à dire qu'est ce qu'on peut
imaginer
comme
modification des courts est comme
processus pour y arriver qu'est ce que
ça suppose est ce que ça suppose de
simplement former les enseignants d'en
trouver d'autres si on en trouve
d'autres les journées ne faisant que 24
heures à quoi est-ce que comment est ce
qu'on fait de l'espace pour que ces
cours puissent prendre place mais c'est
évident que on ne peut plus se contenter
me semble-t-il dans l'enseignement que
vous allez recevoir de se limiter à la
convention humaine monétaire pour
conclure sur des phénomènes qui ont
qui sont avant tout des phénomènes
physiques
pendant longtemps on a pu s'en contenter
en particulier dans un univers en
expansion se préoccuper des limites sont
fous un peu
sauf que malheureusement l'univers en
expansion on en est déjà sorti dans l'
ocde et on va pas tarder à en sortir
dans le monde dans son ensemble et que à
ce moment ça ne suffit plus de se
limiter à la convention économique pour
comprendre ce qui va se passer donc ça
veut dire effectivement que si on va
jusqu'au bout de la logique alors le
fait que je sois là ce matin on est
peut-être déjà une première traduction
mais si on va jusqu'au bout de la
logique la structure de vos cours va
devoir laisser pour laisser plus de
place à la compréhension physique du
monde ce qui n'est pas nécessairement
quelque chose qui demande de faire
beaucoup plus compliqué que direct de
troyes et de la bonne observation 1 mais
ça veut dire quand même que ça va devoir
prendre du temps
temps est limité et c'est la fin de
cette conférence
merci à tous les étudiants pour d'être
venu ici à l'ocp pour pouvoir échanger
un
bon
monsieur
on peut encore prendre une ou deux
questions vous avez proposé une
prolongation rabat au manque de pot le
déjeuner attendre à un quart d'heure de
plus désolé
que tous ceux qui n'ont rien à manger ce
matin au petit déjeuner regrette
amèrement ce qu'ils ont fait
il ya un bras qui sait
à part de cela
[Musique]
l'important ce serait surtout de savoir
ce que vous en pensez vous
en fait
les gens qui
en fait il faut savoir c'est il fausse
pub une information ne vaut rien sans
son processus d'élaboration
donc la bonne question à vous poser
c'est toujours comme ans comment est ce
que je sais ce que je sais sur la bonne
question donc comment est-ce que les
gens qui disent que le rapport du giec
n'est pas rigoureux savent ce qu'ils
disent et bien la réponse c'est qu'ils
n'en savent rien parce que en fait ils
ont résonné à l'envers c'est des gens
qui ont besoin de se rassurer il ya un
petit livre dont je vous conseille la
lecture c'est assez sympa d'un homme qui
s'appelle sébastien molères et ce livre
s'appelle où est le sens alors sébastien
molères a écrit deux bouquins il y en a
qui la fait plus connaître que l'autre
le premier c'est le bug humain dans
lequel il dit si je résume très
rapidement que nous ne sommes pas des
animaux rationnelle mais nous sommes des
animaux qui pilotons rationnellement nos
désirs c'est à dire qu'en fait ce qui
compte vraiment ce qui fait que vous
êtes allé faire le week-end
d'intégration c'est pas la rationalité
si votre striatum là enfoui au plus
profond de votre cerveau qui vous dit
que vous avez 5 pulsions primitives qui
sont mangés le sexe a cumulé de
l'information
grimper dans la hiérarchie et faire tout
ça en dépensant le moins d'énergie
possible donc le et en fait quand vous
regardez le comportement animal c'est
toujours pilotée par c'est par ces trucs
là et par dessus on a rajouté un cortex
qui fait que c'est quand même vachement
plus sympa de grimper dans la hiérarchie
en allant s'envoyer en l'air dans
l'espace comme monsieur bedos et donc
pour ça on fait des tas de calculs
sophistiqués pour faire des fusées mais
c'est bien dans cet ordre là que les
choses se passaient alors dans où est le
sens ils spéculent aussi sur d'autres
traits de caractère et notamment le déni
il explique qu'en fait le déni c'est une
façon de se rassurer pour ceux ramenés à
un univers connu parce que nous avons
besoin pour trouver notre nourriture par
exemple en tant qu'animaux d'évoluer
dans un univers prévisible c'est pour ça
qu'on on aime bien aller chasser à côté
de là où il ya des traces d'animaux
parce qu'on sait que les animaux vont
repasser l'univers est prévisible et
donc nous on va pouvoir prévoir qu'on va
pouvoir trouver à manger
et le ce qu'on a coutume d'appeler le
climato-scepticisme c'est à dire la
contestation de l'existence du problème
en fait c'est une manifestation de sang
c'est une manifestation de dénis pour se
rassurer pour ceux ramenés à un univers
connu donc quand vous regardez les
arguments techniques qui sont invoquées
par les climato sceptiques en fait y en
a pas un qui passe la rampe qu'est ce
que ça veut dire qu'il y en a pas un qui
passe la rampe ça veut dire qu'il n'y en
a pas un qui soit
compatible avec les faits observés tels
qu'ils sont publiées dans la littérature
scientifique dans la littérature
scientifique quand on publie quelque
chose on se fait réfutée par les pairs
c'est ça la grande force la littérature
scientifique alors ça marche très bien
pour les faits c'est évidemment beaucoup
moins bien pour les opinions mais
donc ça donc dans en matière de physique
de chimie de biologie où il ya quand
même beaucoup de fait c'est quand même
une grosse sécurité et ça permet de
séparer en permanence ce qu'on considère
comme un fait acquis et se considère
comme une question qui est toujours en
débat
quand vous regardez d'où viennent les
climato sceptiques c'est que des gens
qui sont rassurés par le déni alors vous
en avez de plusieurs catégories la
première très présente aux états unis
très peu en france et les ultra
religieux pour eux la console à la
conviction qui doit pas être remise en
cause c'est que la marche du monde c'est
la sphère de dieu et donc le fait que
les hommes à l'humanité puisse influer
sur la marche du monde c'est juste un
truc qui n'a aucun sens donc c'est juste
pas possible une deuxième catégorie
c'est les gens qui sont contrariés dans
l'exercice de leur activité par les
conséquences logiques du problème donc
si vous êtes charbonnier ou si vous êtes
pétroliers dans un certain de cas de
figure où si vous êtes simplement un
économiste ultra libérale parce que vous
savez très bien que pour gérer un
problème on va devoir mettre des
contraintes et vous n'avez pas les
contraintes à ce moment vous avez envie
de dire que le changement climatique ça
n'existe pas alors ça peut également
être le cas si vous êtes polytechnicien
retraités
alors pourquoi parce que si vous êtes
polytechnicien vous est plus
intelligente que tout le monde donc
c'est pas possible que vous ayez raté un
problème aussi gros et si vous êtes
retraité ça veut dire que vous l'avez
raté durant votre vie active et en plus
à un moment où vous pouvez plus rien
faire pour corriger le tir donc ça c'est
un truc qui est insupportable et vous
avez un certain nombre de politiciens
retraités qui sont les vieux sont plus
dans les anciens dirigeants les anciens
dirigeants un peu vieux et en
particulier convient des postes
importants sont volontiers un peu
climato sceptiques
notamment à cause de ça donc vous vous
trouvez un certain nombre de catégories
de gens qui contestent si je suis un peu
plus précis le dernier rapport du giec
fait 4000 pages est ce que vous pensez
sérieusement qu'une personne qui va
aller se répandre dans la presse en
disant c'est un manque de rigueur à lui
les 4000 pages est capable de contester
page par page les arguments techniques
qui sont évoqués dans ce rapport
évidemment non
évidemment que non
donc ces gens la trouvent une voie
d'expression dans la presse au nom d'un
droit au débat a invoqué par la presse
qui en l'occurrence est un droit à
l'imposture c'est un droit au débat
totalement dévoyé c'est un peu comme si
à l'école après 1
après après un prof qui vient dire que
la terre est ronde vous en avez un
deuxième qui vient dire que la terre est
plate et ont dit aux élèves maintenant
démerdez-vous pour choisir
là on n'est pas dans le droit au débat
on est dans le droit à l'imposture c'est
à dire que l'un des deux viole
ouvertement un fait acquis
et laisse croire aux gens qui sont en
face que les deux opinions se valent
le giec a notamment pour rôle de séparer
les faits d opinion corse et notamment
son rôle et il se limite aux faits donc
quelqu'un qui va aller dire tout ça
c'est n'importe quoi en fait il faut
qu'ils aient un argument solide
concernant les faits et aujourd'hui
après avoir épluché des dizaines de
publications de climato sceptiques je
n'en ai jamais trouvé un seul
savent aussi je sonne vraiment la fin
des prolongations
merci messieurs jancovici pour cette
conférence d'avoir merci à vous
d'avoir accepté d'échanger avec nous
c'était très instructif je pense
notamment dans le cadre du séminaire
design is tomorrow organisé par monsieur
aurélien inquiet et madame hatcher
l'hôtel mme steinberg
je tiens à remercier également nos
partenaires selon entrepreneurs winston
et la maison de champagne henriot
je vous remercie tous les étudiants
d'avoir alors bien suivi cette
conférence on vous donne prochainement
rendez vous pour des prochaines
conférences et aussi pour doper de
locaux
merci beaucoup et je laisse la parole à
monsieur inquiet
merci merci beaucoup
à nouveau très heureux qu'on ait pu
organiser cette invitation
avec tribune
merci monsieur jancovici je pense que là
alors d'abord vous devez tous dégrisé à
ce stade du week-end d'intégration
mais aussi je pense que c'est très utile
pour poser les enjeux au bon niveau et
donc ça va être très structurant sur la
suite beaucoup d'entre vous ont soulevé
la question de baic est ce que je peux
faire aussi moi en tant qu'individu et
il nous semblait que c'était utile à de
passer un petit message est donc je
passe le micro pour deux minutes à
pierre perret tous qui est un à luminy
de l'école mais qui est aussi professeur
affilié avec qui on a créé beaucoup de
contenu sur les problématiques énergie
et climat
au sein de l'école et qui va vous
présenter une initiative qui je pense
peut faire écho à certaines de vos
questions
merci beaucoup aurélien je me présente
du coup je m'appelle pierre père touché
un ancien de le s&p je vais faire un
petit sondage à main levée qui est-ce
qui entend qui est ce qu'on entend à la
conférence de jean marc jancovici pour
la première fois aujourd'hui en en deux
grandes à hawaï et du monde c'est la
première fois augmenté bon ça va six
plaques non c'est pour la rentrée je
pense que c'est une
s'est plaint d'apprentissage et le prise
de conscience je vais rebondir sur les
quelques questions qui ont été posées
par exemple maintenant on fait quoi
quand on a compris l'ampleur du problème
des défis qui a devant nous qui soit à
l'échelle économique physique etc
moi ce que je vous invite à faire c'est
où poser la question maintenant je fais
quoi
le conjuguer au jeu
qu'est ce que je fais à l'échelle
personnel dans mes changements de
comportement à l'échelle professionnels
donc c'est pour ça qu'on a le cpc pour
se former sur le construire notre avenir
dans notre parcours professionnel l
échelle citoyenne donc c'est le qu'est
ce que je fais est pas qu'est ce qu'on
fait ou qu'est-ce que il doit faire mais
qu'est ce que je fais court pour
participer à affronter ces défis et la
deuxième chose c'est ce que nous qu'est
ce que nous faisons
maintenant pour affronter ces défis et
du coup ce qu'on a lancé
en fin 2020 à la fois avec des élèves
avec des alumni et avec des professeurs
et l'administration de l'école c'est le
réseau le tnc esp transition m work ou
tout l'objectif on a je simplifie en a
trois objectifs le premier c'est alertez
nous comme on le voit aujourd'hui il ya
encore une très grande majorité de
personnes qui en fait on peut être
conscience mais entre avoir conscience
et connaître les sujets il ya un écart
qui est gigantesque donc c'est alertés à
la fois autour de vous et à la plus
grande échelle possible la deuxième
chose c'est se former soi même parce que
là vous venez de prendre simplement
conscience de l'ampleur de ce que vous
ne savez pas et donc ça veut dire qu'en
fait il ya énormément de choses allaient
apprendre et c'est pour ça que je
reviens aussi sur la question qui a été
posée dans la salle d'à côté en fait
quand on est en école de commerce eh ben
il faut aller apprendre plein de choses
d'accord en l'école mais aussi auprès
des usagers auprès des agro il ya plein
de choses à aller faire et du coup
diversifie son son anciennement
donc ça c'est apprendre pour beaucoup
mieux comprendre le problème parce qu'en
fait si vous comprenez pas le problème
ça va être très difficile de motiver les
gens pour agir face à ce problème et
puis la troisième chose c'est essayer de
comprendre comment on peut agir d'accord
et ça comme des gens comme ici c'est
comment on fait pour agir en essayant de
déconstruire tout un tas de croyances
qui conçoit tout un tas de deux modèles
établis dépasser le greenwashing et
comment on construit ensemble en avenir
commun le meilleur possible et donc
l'objectif de le tnc répond à ces trois
questions c'est vous concrètement en
tant qu'élève qui démarrait aujourd'hui
à l'ocp l'a su me fait une petit à petit
un petit point j'ai un ancien de l'école
j'ai fait mon cursus entre 2008 et 2012
à cette époque là entre 2008 et 2012
j'ai jamais entendu parler du sujet
environnement et du sujet climat
aujourd'hui vous commencez me suis
formée après en autodidacte en suivant
par contre en particulier vous cours
et ben vous aujourd'hui vous commencez
dès maintenant dès le premier jour avec
cette prise de conscience donc vous avez
en effet tout votre cursus pour
comprendre comment construire votre
cursus et apprendre tout un tas
connaissance voilà donc nous ce qu'on
veut essayer faire là avec le tn donc le
jeu appelle le s&p transition networks
et ça s'est rassemblée c'est créer des
liens parce que face à ces sujets là
vous allez avoir les halls et que je
prends en europe temps vous allez avoir
un psy gc ou d'un moment vous à dire
waouh ça fait vachement peur qu est ce
que moi je peux faire tout seul quant au
fait quels sujets qui concernent sept
milliards de personnes et ben juste
gérer ce côté peur ce côté un petit mal
être et ben c'est construire ensemble
avec les autres qu'on soit une société
construire créer des liens et donc c'est
ce qu'on essaie de faire là avec le tn
donc vous avez lien pour vous inscrire
c'est le lien vous avez sur linkedin
l'objectif c'est ça c'est créer des
liens entre les profs entre les élèves
avec les alumni parce que les alumni en
fait c'est des professionnels qui sont
des entreprises et du coup tous ces gens
là en collaborant ils peuvent évidemment
travailler à affronter tous ces défis
donc voilà j'ai fait un peu plus long
mais je tenais à vous remercier
aurélien valentina anne-charlotte
laetitia pour possible
donc rendez vous à 13h30 dans vos salles
respectives j'espère que pour tout le
monde c'est clair mais je crois que là
c'est bon aussi dans vos emplois du
temps 13h30 pour la